da bin ich wieder ordentlich gefordert
themen mitgebracht kann bis in bastel stets machen
ach jetzt geht der komodo champ bei mir auch hat ein bisschen gedauert
Exzellent! Muss ich den VM anmachen?
Woher brauchen wir die VM überhaupt?
Bin ich mir sicher?
Ja, brauchen wir wahrscheinlich.
So, dieses Teil habe ich hier rumliegen.
mit aktuell 8 gig ram
und einem reisen 78 40 hs war so immer hat acht kerne 16 mit hyper threading
und ich glaube aktuell ist ein terabyte ssd drin was ich daran geschlossen habe ist eine kvm
gerade dass wir was sehen können ich kann auch gerade mal drauf ich habe eine kvm am start und
wenn wir dann installiert haben und tastatur sharing und gedöns eingerichtet haben dann ja
war ja klar dann switchen auf capture card und auf capture card und monitor aber erst
einmal erst mal so dort das ding hängt im bios weil es nichts zum muten hat wo wir dann gleich
aussort das hier kann ich jetzt mal alles zu machen und wenn das hat sind bei von der vm
überlebt schlecht heckl package updates hier auf der kiste jawohl wir haben erst vor drei stunden
geupdatet natürlich archlinux bei the way hier ist die kiste da war das jetzt also ziel ist
folgendes michael 50 milliarden 67 monate das ist nicht nur hyper subscriber das ist
moment
67 subscriber ich wie dumm das ist eigentlich mit 60 ich kann damit das überhaupt nicht geben
ich weiß gar nicht was die leute an dieser zahl so toll finden 69 war schon lustig was kommt
eigentlich als nächstes 68 weil 69 hatten wir 67 hatten wir da bleibt jetzt eigentlich 68 als nächstes
oder 65
schnell gefuttert naja stunde war ich jetzt weg oder ja
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Einfach nur dumm.
Richtig hängen geblieben, wie man
dazu gesagt hat.
Ne, ne.
Ich will, ich guck da gar nicht rein.
Vergiss, die Seile mach ich nicht auf.
Ne.
96 als nächstes.
Ja, warum nicht?
ähm
chat
vielleicht sollten wir cache us erstmal runterladen
bevor wir überhaupt
was
Moment
Alter bin ich doof
ich muss nichts runterladen
ich hab doch meinen high IQ cloud
pxe installer
da muss nichts runtergeladen werden
boot vom network
das ja gute dates vom vom network eigentlich wartet mal wie wie wie wie starte ich jetzt
jetzt neu. Kann man da Ctrl-Alt entfernen?
Irgendwie drücken? Ich weiß, ich kann hier auf
Change, aber...
Also ich habe diese KVM noch nicht verwendet bisher.
Wie macht man hier
Tastaturpresses? Kann ich einfach so machen?
Ne, das
bringt schon mal nix.
Wie sende ich hier Ctrl-Alt-Delete?
Oh, hat doch
funktioniert. Hat doch funktioniert.
Äh, SK... Ah, ne, ne, ne.
Ich will nicht Setup-Entern.
Ich will, ähm...
Boot-Menü.
Moment, wie komme ich jetzt ins Boot-Menü am besten?
F2 oder sowas vielleicht, hä?
Habt ihr da irgendwas gesehen vom Boot-Menü?
Ne, ne?
Nächst Boot-Menü.
Na egal, dann, warum kann ich nicht sagen, jetzt Netzwerk-Boot?
Soll ich jetzt einfach hier sagen, Network als erstes?
Ja, Moment mal.
Warum?
Warum bootet der dann nicht vom Netz?
Gibt es BIOS, wo Network Boot aus ist?
Kann das sein?
Dass Network Boot deaktiviert ist?
Gibt es sowas?
Aber der Network Boot,
Network Stack Configuration, guck mal!
Der ist disabled!
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das möglich ist überhaupt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das überhaupt...
...auf PXE-Support...
Man kann nämlich Boot hier wieder umstellen.
Ja, USB ist gut, Harddisk.
Network.
NVMe.
So, da sollte es auf jeden Fall Network booten.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay, der macht schon mal was.
Oder auch nicht.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob er Network boot macht.
Alter.
Ach, Moment.
Habe ich überhaupt?
Sekunde.
Alter, bin ich dumm.
Ich habe kein Netzwerkkabel angeschlossen.
Vielleicht braucht man das hier jetzt gar nicht.
Ja, wobei, das hier...
Das hier muss anscheinend auch an
Ja
Aber hier von wegen
Guck mal was er hier schreibt
Media Detect 1
Ach ne der checkt nur
Okay Sekunde Moment
Netzwerkkabel
Okay, jetzt hat er auch einen Link.
Ja, ja, schon viel besser.
Viel besser.
Jetzt gibt es PXE-Bootstells.
So.
Jetzt können wir auch gleich mal testen,
ob mein PXE-Krempel hier funktioniert.
Okay, das von uns schon mal.
Cache.
Cache OS.
Er bootet. Er bootet schon mal.
Lernt man mehr in der Ausbildung? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Moment, da gehe ich mal kurz drauf ein, während Kashi bootet.
Lernt man mehr in der Ausbildung, wenn man zu Hause selber Sachen umsetzt und recherchiert?
Bin bald fertig mit der Ausbildung, fühle mich ultra wie ein Kacknub.
Das ist normal. Man fühlt sich in vielen Bereichen immer wie ein Kacknub.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich es soweit geschafft habe.
So wenig Ahnung kannst du nicht haben.
Aber natürlich lernt man mehr. Und nicht nur in der Ausbildung,
sondern allgemein also ich behaupte einfach mal das meiste habe ich für mich selbst so
im wie sagt man so schön im eigenstudium gelernt als in der ausbildung oder im job
kann es sein dass ich zu wenig ram hab
Error Downloading Cache?
Hä? Warum?
Warum Error Downloading?
Habe ich Mist gebaut?
R-Root-FS?
Sekunde, das muss ich mal checken.
Habe ich nicht vorhin sogar noch Cache gebootet
und dann hat es funktioniert?
R, nicht AI.
Oder? Würde ich sagen R.
Ne, es ist AI-Root-FS.
MonkaS.
also hier tree was doch arch x86 64 er ruht fs hat auch eine ip was sagt er geht nicht http
das ist doppel punkt slash slash 1 und 2.168 punkt 2.55 slash cashie slash arch
slash x86 chat was in der anders gore x6 na oder englischen tastatur 64 gut fs.es
Das geht doch
Ich glaube ich habe zu wenig RAM dafür
Kann das sein
Kann das sein ich habe zu wenig RAM
Das in Speicher
Da zu laden
Das könnte tatsächlich sein, ne?
Ich habe ja nur 8 Gig drin, ne?
Und das ISO ist...
Das hier ist schon 3 Gig.
Und wenn das entpackt wird ins RAM,
ist der RAM wahrscheinlich voll.
Aber ich kann dir empfehlen,
für Projekte daheim,
nimm irgendwas,
was dich persönlich wirklich brennend interessiert.
Naja, also gut, wie gesagt, ich glaube, ich habe hier
Weil das geht ja eindeutig, ja
Ich glaube, ich habe wirklich
Zu wenig, zu wenig RAM
Ja, falls im Saal es 75%
Weil er lädt ja, er fängt ja auch hier an
Runterzuladen, guck
Und dann ist er irgendwann abgebrochen, zwischendurch
Okay, wir probieren das
wir probieren das einmal noch aber wie mache ich hier in dieser kvm ach so welche kvm das ist das
ist eine gl net kvm pro das ist hier die da diese kvm ist das so ein ding wie wie wie sendet man jetzt
jetzt hier control alt delete das ist natürlich wichtig das muss ja relativ
easy gehen virtual keyboard ja aber gibt es da nicht gibt es gibt es da nicht
einen shortcut für hier hier control alt delete jetzt hat er neu gestartet
zumindest tippt jetzt nicht mehr
was für themen interessieren dich denn so was ist so dein lieblingsgebiet
also was mich privat sehr interessiert was aber halt auf der arbeit nichts
bringt ist ich bastel gerne mit microcontroller rum und mit embedded
kram aber das ist jetzt auf der arbeit habe ich das bisher noch nicht gebraucht
vms und linux ja dann let's go das ist beides themen da bringt ihr später auch
im job was so als probier das auch mit cash aus es könnte echt sein dass ich
zu wenig ram habe in der kiste
wie gesagt 3 gig gepackt entpackt ist wahrscheinlich dann einfach die der ram
voll.
Guck, der lädt hier runter.
Und jetzt ist er gleich fertig.
Aber kurz bevor er fertig ist, kackt er ab.
Ja, guck, guck.
Past
Returns
Was auch immer er will.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe zu wenig RAM für die CacheOS, für ISO, für PXE-Boot.
Naja gut, wie dem auch sei.
Vielleicht kann ich hier noch ein bisschen dran rumtweaken, dass das funktioniert.
Probier mal zum Spaß, Debian, ob das geht.
Mach ich, mach ich.
Ich dachte mir, vielleicht können wir hier noch ein bisschen dran rumschrauben.
Weil hier steht drin, Space Size 4 Gig.
Vielleicht soll ich das einfach mal wegmachen.
Wo hier was von 4 Gig steht.
So, aber wir probieren mal Debian aus, du hast recht.
aber letztendlich wir haben ja zeit wir haben ja zeit wir probieren mal die da kann ich zum
ersten mal auf einer echten hardware kiste testen ob mein db an cloud install funktioniert was ich
mir da gestrickt hat mit cloud in it und so weiter gucken wir mal kaste customer ist es
dass der immer so lang braucht zum puten
so
probieren wir mal, Debian installen
da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob mein selbstgestrickter
Krempel funktioniert
äh
Scheiße, es hat funktioniert
Okay, gut. Ich habe jetzt gedacht,
es hängt, aber ne, es hat funktioniert.
Okay, Setup.
Stable.
Äh.
Flash Drive. Ich habe da überhaupt
kein Flash Drive dran.
Swiller.
Okay, NVMe.
Debian, Hostname.
Volle Pulle.
Oh!
Mein Skript ist kaputt.
Das Funst mit NVME ist nicht.
Gut, dass wir es mal ausprobiert haben.
Das ist broken.
Weil...
Okay, mein Skript ist auch dumm.
Ähm.
Moment.
Mein Skript ist auch dumm.
Das hat jetzt überhaupt nichts mit Cache zu tun, aber trotzdem.
Hier, mein...
Mein Skript ist auch dumm.
Das sagt hier irgendwo...
Disk. Guck mal hier.
Disk 1 macht es immer hinten dran.
Aber das ist ja Blödsinn.
Deswegen kommt dann so Zeug raus wie
NVMe 0N11.
Okay, da, ähm...
Warum überhaupt eins?
Das macht doch eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Achso, Mount.
Mount, nee, das ist es nicht.
Ja doch, ja doch, weil da SDA rauskommt.
Ah, ja, ja, okay, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Jetzt verstehe ich das Problem.
Also, guck mal, das Problem ist, bei Festplatten kommt SDA raus.
Oder bei alten SATA SDA.
Und dann mache ich SDA1 raus.
Bei NVMe kommt NVMe 01N1P1 dabei raus.
Der Name ist anders.
Also muss ich quasi checken,
if
ähm
Warte mal hier.
Disk
Das muss ich checken.
If Disk
Wenn das
NVMe enthält,
ja,
dann
sagt mir, ob ich hier Mist baue,
Dann, wenn das NVMe enthält, dann will ich nicht das hier machen.
Das will ich machen im Else.
Sondern ich will sagen, P1.
Ja, so schnell wie leicht.
Das ist doch, oder? Stimmt das, was ich hier gebaut habe?
Ähm.
Ne, das ist nicht gewagt, dass 1 immer die richtige Partition ist.
Weil, guck mal, ich download mir das Debian-Image.
DD ist auf die Platte.
Und bei dem Debian-Image ist es immer so,
dass die erste Partition das ist, was ich mounten will.
Kannst du gegebenenfalls den Titel anpassen?
Habe ich doch.
Cache-OS auf Ryzen-Mini-PC taugt das.
Falls du die ganze Zeit noch im Chat warst,
musst du den mal reloaden.
Dann siehst du...
Stable.
NVMe.
Mal gucken, ob ich das richtig gebaut habe da.
Achso, okay
Ähm
Ilex ist ja
Das ist jetzt doof, wenn es zweimal gelaufen ist, ne
Okay, nochmal
Zack, zack, oh, oh, oh
Abbrechen, abbrechen
Selected Disk SDA, ich weiß nicht mal, was SDA ist
Äh, NVMe
Demion Host, okay
So, jetzt mal gucken, ob jetzt mein
Garmfonds, den ich da gescriptet habe.
Ah, jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Jetzt ist Debian installiert.
Okay, siehste?
Script schon wieder gefixt. Nice.
So, gucken wir mal,
ob Debian jetzt bootet.
Bootchamp.
Gibt es eigentlich sowas?
Debian lädt. Nice.
Funst.
so schnell habt ihr noch nie eine installation gesehen außer man skript gefixe
bootcamp ich wollte gucken gibt es eigentlich schon was was ein bootcamp gibt es aber gut
champ gibt es schon das gibt es schon für mac os guck mal hier so 21 ihr setzt haben wir hier
guck dem jahr 40 jetzt sind wir auf der demian kiste das ging schnell das war echt ist das muss
ich mir auch anschauen das gibt es nirgendwo das habe ich selbst geskript dort
du kannst ja aber den stream anschauen wo wir das gebaut haben zum grün zum
größten teil das funktioniert soll ich mal kurz soll ich mal kurz zeigen wie
das funktioniert dieses dieser schnelle db an install okay wir haben wir haben
zeit wir haben zeit ich zeige ich zeig das mal kurz das ist richtig das ist
richtig high iq finde ich also ich habe hier einen web server nix und ein dns
mask laufen die torrent files ja klar das wollte ich jetzt sagen die die die
die pxe boot geschichte so zeige ich jetzt nicht zeigt nur ich zeige nur die
debian teil ok kc tv weil das wird sonst mit uns zu lang genau also per dns mask
wird dann das pxe boot ausgeliefert dann startet der ipx und sonst was sondern
sondern bist im Menü und drückst auf Install.
Sobald du Install auswählst, dann lädt er das hier.
Also ich bin schon im richtigen Ordner.
Dann lädt er das hier.
Der lädt einen Linux-Körnel von hier und eine Init-RAM-FS von hier.
Die habe ich selbst gebaut, dieses Minimal-Linux.
Da gab es hier ein Docker-File.
Wo er folgende Dinge macht.
er installiert erstmal linux kölner job für ssh installt kürzer da bla bla bla also er hat hier
einen innenraum auf es habe ich gebaut für mich für meine zwecke da sind auch so ein paar sachen
trainer wie dass ich diese tools hier zur verfügung habe und ein skript was der mir
rein kopiert in diese innenraum fs das ist das woran sich dann quasi auch hochzieht ist dieses
Setup.sh. Setup.sh ist ein ganz simples Skript, was nichts anderes macht, wie Install.sh von meinem Web-Server zu wgetten und auszuführen.
Install.sh liegt hier und das läuft dann los, sobald du Setup.sh in der Shell eintippst.
Als erstes fragt er dich, was du installieren willst.
Debian, Testing, Stable oder SID.
Also Stable, Testing oder Unstable.
Dann als nächstes fragt er dich, auf welcher Festplatte du das installieren willst.
Das macht er, indem er sich mit LSBLK den Device-Typ rausholt.
Kannst du ja auswählen in der FZF-GUI.
Merkt sich die Disk.
Dann holt er sich den Random-Namen für den Host-Namen raus.
fragt dich, ob er den Host-Namen benutzen soll.
Dann holt er das Debian Cloud Image.
Hier, das liegt hier.
Debian Testing Stable Sit.
Das lädt er sich einmal in der Woche nachts runter.
Dann curlt er sich von meinem Web-Server
das Debian...
Das Daily Debian Distro Image.
Das ist LZ4 komprimiert.
Warum LZ4?
Weil LZ4 eine super Kombination ist
aus Speicherersparnis
und sehr schneller anzip performance das heißt ich muss nicht so viel über das netzwerk übertragen
auf die kiste dieses dann installiert so dann mit lz 4 decrypted geguckt wie schneller schreibt und
dann wird es auf die disk die mich oben ausgewählt habe die date das cloud image das geht relativ
schnell dann macht er diese in der drama fs sich in den app verzeichnis guckt wenn es eine wenn es
der nv me ssd ist die erste partition von der ssd wenn es eine normale platte ist maute der die erste
partition von der normalen platte dann und jetzt kommt trick 17 jetzt kommt trick 17 dann geht er
hier in diesem gemeldeten system wir sind immer noch in der in der drama fs drin aber ich kann
mir schon das system was ich auf die platte die date habe dort mountain so dann geht er hier rein
nach etc cloud cloud cfg d dort legt eine 99 custom hin 99 kassen cfg die kommt auch vom
web server die zeit ich dir gleich danach speicherte sich noch den host
namen und machten zirken sleep an mauren zink und dann restartet er in das system
so und jetzt kommt trick 17 config es gibt noch nichts es gibt noch nichts auf
github aber ich mache das ich mache das auf github konfigs so 99 custom config
dort liegen cloud in sachen und man muss cloud in den sagen man möchte kein cloud
in it machen klingt erstmal wir aber wir wollen wir sind bei keinem cloud
anbieter und wollen uns von da nichts runterladen sondern wir wollen local das
ganze machen und zwar meine cloud in it config kommt von meinem web server slash
configs so und das liegt alles hier da gibt es eine network config in das ist
ganz normales cloud in it wie bei einer bieber hetzer zum beispiel gibt es eine
network cloud konflikt die sagt okay alle netzwerk interface ist die mit e
sternchen anfangen und ethernet adapter die mit e sternchen anfangen den ersten
hinter davon findet wer soll eth0 genannt werden und darauf machen wir dhcp
als nächstes kommt user data vendor und metadata sind leer ja was steht da
eigentlich in config selbst hier drin.
Ah, ja genau.
Es gibt UserData. In UserData
steht nichts weiter drin, als dass
er sich seine CloudInitConfig
von hier ziehen soll
und den Hostnamen setzen
soll. Und meine eigentliche Config,
was er dann
letztendlich ausführt, ist das hier. Das ist eine
CloudInitConfig, die ist dann für alle Debian-Systeme gleich.
DisableRootAccess,
ManageETCHost,
da bin ich mir gerade, achso, das ist
dass er den haus namen jetzt die haus setzt das dann nicht nur lokal aus drin steht sondern club
debian champ oder wie auch immer ich das genannt haben dann kopiert er hier mein ssh key in die
autorize an public ssh key in die autorize keys rein sagt passworte expire nicht alle default
user angelegt und dann nachdem er fertig ist schreibt er noch das hier das ist super magic
wenn das hier in meiner etc ist drin steht das hier wenn das in meiner etc
ist drin steht dann gibt debian einmal beim starten wie ihr hier seht die ip
adresse aus die mit der das ding gerade konfiguriert ist das heißt ich sehe auch
hier auf dem prompt quasi oder auf blogging screen wenn ich mich per ssh
verbinden will die ip gleich so dann installierten installiert er noch ein
basic tools hier thema top wird wort 3 nc du bla bla bla dann guckt danach ist es eine vm
wer kiste wenn es eine vm wer kiste ist dann zählt der open vm tools wenn es der kvm kiste
ist in zählt der co imo guest agent und als letztes schaltet noch den maus support für
wim aus ans lieb der mal eins und ist fertig so das war jetzt schnell durchgang hat sie alles
verstanden?
Das war wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu viel, aber
war immer.
Das ist etwas aufwendiger.
Da haben wir eine ganze Weile dran rumgebastelt
im Stream. Okay, jetzt starte ich
neu und jetzt hoffe ich, dass ich nochmal Cache.ios
starten kann.
Mit der neuen Boot-Option. Ansonsten
können wir als nächstes was ausprobieren.
Nämlich, diese
kvm kann angeblich auch iso images uploaden und dann dort mountain
ach guck mal hier kann ich jetzt sagen px
gegen das dd moment die frage muss ich jetzt die check ich kann nicht ging das
Idee nicht auch mit Netcat
anstatt mit Curl. Das würde den
Download in den RAM ersparen, oder?
Äh.
Hä?
Was meinst du jetzt?
Wie, warum hat er jetzt nicht gebootet?
Warum hat er jetzt nicht, bin ich jetzt dumm?
Warum hat er jetzt nicht gebootet?
Geht doch. Achso, der hat Timeoutet.
Okay. Das muss mir mal...
Das muss mir mal... Was? Was meinst du?
Netcat?
Du meinst hier jetzt, ne? Hier im Updates-Skript.
Also nehmen wir mal hier irgendwie das da.
Ah, du meinst... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Du meinst...
Du meinst hier, oder?
Das da?
Der macht das ja schon on the fly.
Curl haut das hier Standard-Out raus.
LZ4 entpackt es.
Dann wird es dedet.
Also da landet nicht viel im RAM.
Das geht quasi von Download auf die Disk.
das sind immer nur ein paar megabyte buffer im ram also köln haut ist ja während dem download
standard raus lz 4d komprimiert das jetzt zeigt einfach an wie viel es ist und dann die data
wie zu wenig ram war war war war war cash ios war zwar zu wenig ram und das kann durchaus sein
weil ich meine muss ja das ganze iso runterladen und das in ram entpacken das könnte 80 könnte bei
einem 3 gigabyte iso doch tatsächlich etwas wenig sein ja jetzt noch mal jetzt habe ich
diese komische setting daraus gemacht also dann kann sie den px e server bauen wo du
isos darüber starten kannst beziehungsweise in sachen die du aus dem iso extra das ist dann
relativ relativ einfach aber dieses extra zeug was ich für die db an cloud install gemacht habt
das schon ein bisschen etwas gewesen ich habe halt noch acht gigabyte kommt er mit dem neuen
das tag pack scheiße okay das von sich glaube ich glaube ich glaube ich glaube wirklich das
ist das problem ich habe zu wenig ich habe zu wenig ram ich habe ich habe ich zu wenig
haben weil weil wenn ich das hier mache auf der kiste mit 16 g gramm 32 tings
was man auf ich mache das jetzt mal hier auf der vm mit 16 g gramm
Jetzt noch kein Swap an der Stelle.
Cashy? Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal.
Vielleicht ist ja mein Cashy-Download auch kaputt gewesen.
Schauen wir mal, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
ja nee guck easy jetzt auf der vm funzt ich habe zu wenig ram 8 gig 8 gig reichen nicht für px
e-cash boot wie es aussieht sehr gut na gut dann müssen wir ein weiteres feature testen nämlich
angeblich kann man mit der kvm die die kaffee das ist aber ordentlich 26 gig ISO files das
kann immer schlecht oder 26 gig storage in der in der kvm integriert der schluss download
müssen wir cash us erstmal runterladen das geht voll klar ja was ich ausprobieren wollte ob man
sich per ssh auf die kvm verbinden kann das irgendwie ssh oder so ich habe irgendwie so
mal gesehen hier wo könnte das denn sein
remote device setting aus
Hä?
Geh mir nicht mit Cloud-Service auf den Sack.
Security. 2FA-Login.
Reboot.
Hm. Wo gibt es hier
einen... Soll ich... Ich könnte das einfach mal ausprobieren.
SSH?
Yes.
Achso.
Connection not using a post quantum key exchange. Ja, das ist für die
Wisst ihr was das passwort war 1 2 3 4 5 6
Ja aber irgendwie wo kommt wo
Wie
Wie schaltet man das ein oder aus überhaupt, SSH?
Und wie setzt man das Passwort?
Also, ich wusste, warum es 123456 ist,
weil das Admin-Frontend auch 123456 als Passwort von mir gesetzt hat.
Also anscheinend benutzen die für root das gleiche Passwort wie hier.
Hast du Tipps gegen einen Sehensschein?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
So, was da drauf läuft, das ist eine gute Frage.
ip-ad und schon mal okay cut etc
gelix bild ruht okay an einem minus
das ist irgendwas zu eigens zusammengebautes von denen gibt kein debian release kein red
release kein ubuntu release oder sonst was könnte man raum das ist auch wert wie
wie kommst du darauf wie kann man das nachgucken
was hat apk was hat was hat auch wert für ein package manager
O-PK?
Ne, hat es auch nicht.
PKG?
PKG-Info?
Python-Package?
ETC?
OS?
OS-Release!
Okay, auf einem Ubuntu haben sie es gebaut.
Da gibt es kein Package.
Aber ich weiß, wir sind
hardcore extrem
sidetracked. Aber,
Leute, aber,
was ich jetzt einfach ausprobieren muss,
das geht jetzt nicht anders,
Arch64.
Ich muss das jetzt einfach ausprobieren.
Nee, ich will wissen, ob da
ein Hello World
Go Binary draufläuft.
KVM Champ.
App, Main,
Go. Ganzen Scheiß hier schmeiß ich raus.
Wobei, komm.
immer mal ist immer ordentlich gold und das sondern container bau was jetzt
Welcher Ryzen Mini PC ist das?
Ein Beelink SR7.
SER7.
Vielleicht war mein Lokal-Docker-Image.
Der spackt da bestimmt wieder rum.
Weil er irgendwelche Sachen gecached hat,
die er nicht cachen soll und sonst was.
Außerdem,
bisschen, bisschen Platz schaffen ist auch nicht verkehrt.
So, drei Stunden später.
Ja, Docker, delete
mal ein bisschen schneller.
Okay.
Gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Okay, jetzt scheint es zu gehen.
Der hat irgendeinen Mist gecached.
Ich weiß, das ist super krasses Sidetracking,
aber ich will gucken, ob dein Basic Go,
ob ich Custom Software quasi
auf meine KVM kopieren
kann und dort laufen lassen kann.
Und Go ist da einfach das Simpelste.
Erstmal drei Stunden Container bauen und
eine IDE starten für Hello World in Go.
Aber hey,
was man nicht alles macht.
Nee, die wird nicht geprickt
Was würdest du denn darauf laufen lassen?
Keine Ahnung
Ich weiß es nicht, es geht mir einfach nur darum, ob es geht oder nicht
Ich will einfach nur wissen, ob es funktioniert
Oh, Meteor ist mitrig für die KVM
Ja?
irgendwas, will mir schon mal sein fallen
und wenn nett ist auch
geht es einfach nur darum, kann man was drauf laufen lassen
ja oder ne
ok, äh, yes
schließen
PXE-Bude auf KVM
an sich
eine gute Idee
aber man will ja die KVM
abstöpseln und neu anstöpseln und sowas
für PXE willst du ja laufen
was haben, also willst du ja was haben, was läuft
alles und im Netz hängt
wallpaper ja das hat sind viele wallpapers drin
und ein skript was automatisch wallpapers wechseln du kannst ja einfach auch die raussuchen die der
besten gefallen wenn nun weitere ideen hast du wallpaper sagt bescheid
so drei stunden später ist die idee auf
ok der kvm champ da ist er öffnen workspace app das window gut
ja guck du hast ja alle möglichen bilder sogar für unterschiedliche jahres nicht
jahreszeiten tageszeiten also main go wir schmeißen alles hier raus alles weg
sagen einfach nur noch fmt trittel high iq chat bestes programm überhaupt
jetzt sagen wir bild.sh würde ich sagen aber moment moment wenn er jetzt mal
kann man nicht machen das können wir nicht machen
dass das kann man nicht machen
dass das gibt nichts wir müssen hier sagen hier cgoe-enabler
goos go arch gibt es doch irgendwie sowas oder go arch
ja go arch valid targets was gibt es denn da alles
was brauche ich
Arch
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
das ist ein 64-Bit-Arm-CPU,
oder?
Ah, Arch 64.
Also Arm 64 müsste das richtige sein.
Okay.
Das dürfte jetzt hier jetzt nicht laufen.
Genau.
Arm Arch 64.
Okay.
Ja gut.
Dann App.
SSH.
genauso jetzt scp app dahin massive passwort okay so jetzt haben wir hier unsere go app drauf
funktioniert ich kann programm auf meiner kvm ausführen nice das wollte es das muss sein
Ist das nicht nice?
Custom GoPro-Kram auf der KVM.
Aber jetzt mal zurückzukommen.
Eigentlich wollten wir CacheOS installieren.
Und wofür? Weil es geht.
Nicht, dass das irgendwie Sinn machen würde.
Das habe ich ja nicht gesagt.
oder eine best war der coole sache ich weiß noch nicht wofür aber das kann man bestimmt
mal gebrauchen so also gehen wir mal weiter auf die kvf jetzt müssen wir hier wird schon
media klick to upload file downloads cash ios
der upload auf die kvm dauert länger als der download aus dem internet
askiquarium ist in pearl programmiert ich glaube aber chat wenn ihr sagt das ist ein
OpenWrt oder sowas.
Dann
kann man dann PackageManager nicht
nachinstallieren, wenn
BuildRoot das nicht dabei hat. Wie geht's
der Meats?
Ich hab keine Cuts mehr.
Die leben alle nicht mehr.
Es gibt was?
GoQuarium. Gibt das wirklich?
GitHub?
Wo ist es?
Ah.
Exzellent.
Ja, das brauchen wir doch.
Das ist ganz essentiell.
Moment.
Jetzt Clone.
Moment, äh, Boaquarium?
Äh, Moment, wie war das, wie war das, äh, GoArch gleich ARM64?
GoS gleich Linux.
Okay
SCP
Go Quarium
Auf die KVM
Okay
Go Quarium, jawoll
Beste, Leute
Go Quarium auf der KVM
Wichtig und richtig, genau
Bisschen laggy ist es vielleicht
bisschen laggy ist es und es sind viel zu viele gleiche fische hier unterwegs
aber es funktioniert immerhin exzellent gut dass wir das geklärt haben also ist
der upload fertig von meiner iso ja ist fertig mount
geht das jetzt so und image
was
okay whatever keine ahnung reboot tut ihr hin und toolbox
Ist es gemountet?
Es ist gemountet.
Äh.
Okay, Moment.
Das Reboot nicht.
Echo B.
Nach.
Rock.
Sys.
RQ Trigger.
Bam.
Das ist Hard Reboot unter Linux.
Wenn nichts gespeichert oder irgendwas.
Könnt ihr euch merken.
Wenn es mal wieder hängt und gar nichts geht.
Echo B-Proxys-RQ-Träger.
Das geht immer.
Ja, Flashdrive.
Hashi OS.
Wofür B steht, keine Ahnung.
Es gibt da irgendwie 10, 12 verschiedene Sachen, die man da reinpipen kann.
Alle machen ein bisschen was anderes.
Was kostet die KVM? Weiß ich gerade aus dem Kopf nicht mehr.
Hält sich aber in Grenzen.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie teuer KVMs früher waren.
120 Euro oder sowas.
Okay, der ist hier wild am rumpieren.
So, jetzt müsste Cashew eigentlich starten.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
So, während Cashew es lädt, könnt ihr ja die Zeit nutzen,
wenn ihr es noch nicht habt, jetzt zu folgen.
Für die nächsten Streams.
Seid wieder
top aktuell mit am Startzeit.
Ah, jetzt lädt es.
Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen, es braucht ganz schön lang.
106,90 Barmherzog.
Guck mal bei denen auf der Seite.
Ach, guck mal. Ohne Mist.
Das ist gar nicht... Also ich hätte
es mir laggier vorgestellt.
Das geht sogar halbwegs.
dafür dass es über kvm ist also ich hätte mir das ich hätte mir das mehr
mehr lecky vorgestellt kann man da vielleicht die die auflösung noch ein
bisschen höher machen ehrlich die auflösung 1920 1080 ist vielleicht
besser
Kann man da vielleicht die Datenrate irgendwie...
Hast du den mal geupdatet, Max?
Was denn?
Selfmade Eyes, danke schön für den Sub!
Massive Subscription.
Hast du die KVM geupdatet?
Nö.
Ich hab die noch nicht groß benutzt.
Vielleicht soll ich die mal updaten.
Ja, ja, der hat auch ein Update.
Aber das mach ich jetzt nicht.
Wo kann man hier die Qualität...
Seht ihr irgendwas, wo man die Qualität einstellen kann von dem Stream?
Mode?
normal doch nicht so smart der mode ultra high
jetzt geht nichts mehr aus als aus aus ultraheit
Okay, aber vielleicht doch mal wieder Medium.
Ich glaube Cashew hat den Geist aufgegeben, kann das sein?
Smart?
Äh, nee
Ja, Cash.io erst hat den Geist aufgegeben, glaube ich
Ich restart mal kurz die KVM, vielleicht ist es besser
Ah, jetzt geht es wieder, okay, gut
Fullscreen
ok lounge installer
gleich wegen dem Resizen, ja kann sein
installer pausierungs champ
ok american english next europe berlin richtig germanie die falls ehrlich gesagt germanie
notet keys sind mir lieber was es irgendwie nicht zur auswahl gibt dann default was nehmen
wir für ein boot manager chat ich will ja btfs snapshots letzten mal in der vm was probiert
hat mir die mine das war eigentlich ganz nice ansonsten nehmen wir den klassiker
schlechthin gruppe gruppe now that keys now that keys ist zum beispiel kommt mal
wenn du hier ich weiß nicht wie man das zeichen nennt wenn du dieses es geht
nämlich auch gerade nicht ja wenn du
Wenn du dieses Hütchen hier tippst, ne?
Das musst du normalerweise zweimal drücken, dass es kommt.
Ne, Zirkumflex ist...
Zirkumflex ist das hier, glaube ich.
So, und ich muss es nur einmal drücken, dass es kommt.
Sonst musst du es zweimal drücken, hintereinander.
Okay, hier, also, Limine.
Achso, ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist denn da drauf?
Ja, klar, mein Debian war jetzt drauf,
Erased Disk.
BTFS, Encrypt System.
Wir testen das jetzt mal.
123456 das ist nichts was ich da lange drauf hat massive 123456 plasma erstmal
kde plasma caches packages niri way fire sway wir lassen das erste mal aber
printing support können wir mit installieren
Existibility Tools brauchen wir nicht. Alles klar. Next. What is your name? Max.
Massive Passwort. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Install. Install now. Bam. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was CacheOS so treibt.
Creating new root partition.
Äh,
Cachy?
Ah.
Ich würde sagen, was macht der so lange rum?
Ranking Mirrors.
Guck mal mal zu, was er macht.
Okay.
Wir sehen, dass wir nichts sehen.
Ja, was ich für Keyboard-Sharing benutzen werde, dann ist das hier.
Deskflow. Das habe ich mal vor einer Weile gefunden auf GitHub.
und das gute ist damit kann man keyboard und maus zwischen computern scheren und
clipboard und wailand ist angeblich auch supported also das ist genau das was wir
brauchen aber ich wette mit dir mit euch dass irgendwas wailand mäßiges garantiert
nicht funktionieren wird weil das ist es wäre zu einfach wenn das mit wailand alles geht
Ja, Barrier wird ja glaube ich nicht mehr
updated.
So, bevor ich das Ding jetzt noch kaputt mache mit meinem Rumgewackel, lasse ich mal lieber
die Finger von der Maus.
Okay.
Ich könnte Deskflow schon runterladen für Windows.
Deskflow, GitHub.
Aber ich habe nämlich gesehen, da gibt es eine Portable Edition.
Nicht ganz nice, finde ich.
Assets, geht weg.
Assets, Windows, Windows, Portable 7 Zip.
Die Frage ist, was hat mehr Saft, die KVM oder Raspberry Pi?
Mit Sicherheit Raspberry Pi.
Ich glaube nicht, dass in der KVM irgendwas sonderlich leistungsstarkes drin ist.
VNC hat auch Support.
So, hier, Deskflow.
Check for...
Nein.
Leute, ich update nichts mehr automatisch, außer meinen Browser wegen Supply Chain Angriffen.
Ich sage Notepad++ und alles mögliche.
Use this computer's skill, make this as a server.
Yes.
Start.
Windows!
Alter!
Fuck, alter Windows,
Mann, geh mir doch nicht auf den Sack!
Ich wette mit euch, da ist nichts Bösartiges drin in dem Projekt.
Falsche Art.
Nee, Windows-Shit.
releases vielleicht was älteres guck mal das 22 days ago das reicht natürlich wir nehmen wir
okay wir nehmen wir nehmen die release version okay wir nehmen die letzte release version die
müsste doch funktionieren
Die geht bestimmt.
Oh, thanks.
Yes.
Ah, jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt geht es.
Alles klar.
Na dann.
All done.
Cash US, installed, restart now.
Gibt es nicht auch die Möglichkeit, rein zu CH-Routen in die neue Installation?
Egal.
Weil ich hätte gerne noch SSH installiert.
Da unten fehlt ein Stück.
Equate.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob das alles ordentlich startet.
Cache US.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist das Live.
Moment, stop mounting.
Okay, nochmal neu starten.
Jetzt hätte ich ja fast die Live-CD wieder gestartet.
Ah, da sind wir.
Excellent.
HashiOS.
Achso, jetzt muss ich natürlich mein Passwort gleich noch eingeben.
123456, massive secret Passwort.
Probiert nie einer aus.
Da sind wir!
Kann man Autologin machen?
sind wir cash ios
excellent so als wir so kurz mit einer sache will ich noch machen nämlich
auto login weil es mir sonst später auto login
login das macht man doch bestimmt login screen
automatically login as user max with kde wayland
apple k last mal kurz check session restart aber moment
klappt so schatter und immerhin nicht
schatter und restart das ist blöd das
ist noch bis riss da so jetzt ist da
leben wir noch tastaturen maus sharing
und dann schließen wir mal monitor dran
an und gucken was sache ist
da muss ich den rechner hier abmachen
und rüber stellen dass die geschalte
monitor drankommen
bei gucken wie viel wie viel platz habe ich hier mit capture card wie weit geht
die das könnte reichen doch die capture card reicht euer capture card und
monitor muss ja dahin ich hoffe dass das könnte bis knapp werden
schauen wir machen ich stelle das ich stelle es lieber um gleich stellt gleich
lieber um.
Ah, Moment, Moment.
Vorher. SSH-Unlock
müssen wir noch machen.
Wie macht man gescheit SSH-Unlock?
Weil ohne SSH-Unlock
ist halt zack.
Was für eine CPU und GPU
ist in dem Ryzen drin?
Kann ich dir zeigen. Warte mal.
Sekunde.
Terminal. Was ist vorinstalliert?
A la Kritik.
aber diesen mist hier eigentlich ausblenden
ich wirklich nochmal ach ja was moment das ist ein arzt das ist ja ein arzt haben wir hier das
wollte ich gerade mal haben wir hier haben wir nicht haben paru paru paru
nv top installieren wir jetzt mal für die grafikkarte
yes
der macht auch snapshots nv top also was haben hier wir haben eine m eine amd
radion 780 m und wir haben auf die tat ob es auch fisch das ist eine fisch
shell monka esse okay da müssen wir gleich gleich ein bisschen dran rum
oder haro h top
so und wir haben hier acht kerne bzw mit hyperthreading 16 also das ist schon so
für so ganz kleinen pc ist und hatte schon ordentlich ordentlich wumms da
muss man mal sagen ich dachte ich habe 8 g gramm
Äh.
Ähm.
Moment.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz auf mein Handy gucken,
was ich bestellt habe.
ja kein wunder wenn das ding nur acht ggs war also ich habe ja den rahmen aus meinem nass genommen ja
den rahmen riegel aus meinem nass so hier nass oder details
Da sieht man mal wieder nichts gescheit. Aber da steht 8gig RAM.
Ich muss jetzt ins Bios gucken. Im Bios sieht man das wahrscheinlich besser.
Was ist das denn?
mach mal die eko decode zudem
ok nach was soll ich alles was soll was soll ich ausschalten
4 GB Chat für die GPU
Achso, das wird davon abgeknipst
oder was
DMI Code
minus T Memory
8 Gig?
Soll ich doch.
Das ist für die GPU ist da.
Wo habt ihr das jetzt gesehen?
Hier.
Moment, warum hat meine GPU so viel?
Das brauche ich überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Reboot.
Die GPU kriegt auf jeden Fall weniger RAM.
das ist ja was das heckel so etwa 12 stellt man dann sowas ein chipset south
bridge
Northbridge? Nee.
Advanced.
Main wird es nicht sein. Advanced.
PCI-Subsystem?
Nee.
Stellt mir das ein.
Ist das überhaupt ein BIOS-Setting?
Ist das ein OS-Setting?
network stack ist es nicht usb configuration ist es net pci subsystem setting ist es nett
cpu das wird es nicht sein mit cbs cpu configuration meinst du es ist er
Nee.
Was?
GFX-Configuration.
Ist das das?
Chat?
Uma-Frame-Buffer-Size 4GB?
Ist das das?
Komm.
256 reicht doch für...
500...
256 reicht.
Was ist eine gute Größe?
512?
512.
Safe changes, yes.
Durchdrehen.
Was passiert,
wenn du es auf 8 Gig stellst?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Out of memory im bios
Okay, da ist er wieder
Kann ich immer zurück stellen im bios, weil das bios out of memory geht
Ich komme hier das ist das ist mega nice ich habe jetzt hier alle meine snapshots im boot manager
Und wenn ich mein system zerschossen habe kann ich auf dem snapshot stand zurück das eigentlich
Exzellent!
sagen wir gucken uns an wie man das war nie mal ja und ssh ssh auch ja ja ja genau es ist auch
open ssh
aber finde ich nervig da muss man immer hoch scrollen ich installiere jetzt mal das was ich
kenne
ob messer
dann werden wir gut und aktivieren ssh service system ctl in nebel ssh dna
So, was für eine IP haben wir?
140.
Da können wir jetzt nämlich hier hingehen.
unser SSH-1.
40. Bam.
Moment, ist da eine Firewall an?
Kann das sein?
Firewall-Champ?
Wenn man sich ja nicht drauf connecten kann.
Gibt es da einen Firewall-GUI? So was habe ich noch nie.
Anscheinend gibt es da einen GUI für.
Also normalerweise hätte ich jetzt
gesagt,
UFW-Allow-SSH, aber
man könnte es ja mal wie der letzte K-Klub
über das GUI machen. Add-Rule.
Und jetzt was hier?
SSH oder wie?
in coming create und 236 messwort okay und jetzt xs hs da sind wir so jetzt wie macht man jetzt
SSH
Unlock.
Wobei, vielleicht machen wir zuerst mal
Vielleicht machen wir zuerst mal
das mit der Capture Card.
Du hast den Key nicht geprobt.
Oh, fuck. Seid ihr schon drin, Chat?
Also, soweit ich das sagen würde,
müssen wir Drop
ob wir installieren ja also wir kommen vielleicht gibt es ja ein guide für cash ios ssh unlock
ssh
anlockt was meinst du mit ssh an lockt dass du per ssh da eine festplatte entsperren kannst beim
system boot das geht ja ja das geht aber auch im stream schon gemacht
geht das mit lieben geht das mit dem ein überhaupt gut es läuft danach wie
mein aber nur wenn man das partitionieren feuerbeiß müssen wir
jetzt mal gucken fdx minus über das maus fdx minus wir haben eine partie
war partizipal 1 für evie und das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren
das steht im archwiki garantiert also geht mit shop irgendwie
der remote über ssh genau was das wollen wir haben hatten vorbereiten raid evie
verschlüsselung kripp setup lvm einrichtungen aber nicht formativen einhänger verzeichnet
dafür in den rahmen fest einstellen das brauchen wir okay scanshop er ist das h starten skript
zum öffnen der festplatte passwortabfrage genau genau dass das brauchen wir die frage ist okay
es ist ein Lux, also brauchen wir eigentlich
nur Crypt, äh,
Crypt, ähm, Lux,
ne, äh, Crypt Open, oder?
Crypt, Crypt Open?
Och, Gott, wie heißt das?
Wie, wie? Lux Open?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das von uns, äh, Crypt, Crypt,
Crypt Setup Open?
Ja, Crypt Setup Lux Open.
Okay, Crypt, Crypt Setup ist, ähm,
dabei.
Ja gut, dann probieren wir das mal.
Drop here, init, ram,
in den tram fs das da bin ich mal gespannt ob wir das jetzt hinkriegen
haupt hoch zu installieren job mit dem in early users base das wird es
wahrscheinlich sein
gucken wir mal den guide hier an
das ist schon mal 14
Du brauchst Chopper.
Ja.
Okay, warte mal. Arch, Wiki,
Chopper, SSH.
Crypt.
Chopper, Unlock. Ich habe das lange nicht mehr
gemacht.
Manjaro,
es soll mir auch recht sein.
ja vor sieben jahren keck er nicht
remote unlocking or unlocking partition additionally one more looks encrypted
this can be achieved by using one or more hooks system d based in a drama es
jetzt wird es aber jetzt wird es aber hier richtig advanced
da mal gucken wie das funktioniert okay was was steht bei mir hier drin oder besser gesagt
barcache hier drin files modules hucks muss dann da was rein hucks base system
auto detect sd encrypt das ist wahrscheinlich das ding und da muss
dann rein.
SD Network?
SD Tiny SSH?
Sollte man nicht Job nehmen?
Chatge? Sekunde, ich muss mal ganz dringend
kurz pinkeln.
Sei wieder da.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Da bin ich wieder.
als remote ssh lux
hier haben einen guide hier haben einen guide excellent
remote unlocking auf luxus on arch
ein musik ist besser hier ist ein system die extras
ich sehe schon wieder dass wir super advanced
alter übertreibt nicht ich jetzt okay wir machen es jetzt einfach mal so
Oder was?
Was benutzt denn der Typ dafür dann?
Äh, ihr was benutzt
ihr denn für einen SSH-Server überhaupt?
Achso, der benutzt Tailscale und nicht SSH.
Ja, ne, also mit Tailscale fangen wir jetzt nicht an.
Securing the unencrypted...
Warum Tiny SSH?
Warum nicht Drop...
Hier.
ok wir machen job hier machen wir ok also dass wir wollen auf jeden fall
das wollen wir also wir müssen auf jeden fall dass da installieren so viel so viel steht schon mal
fest.
Ist das ein guter
Geiter?
Die was?
Ob ich was benutze?
Okay.
Also, jetzt haben wir hier, jetzt haben wir Dropbeer da drin eingebaut.
Jetzt.
M-Catings Utils.
ok machen wir jetzt einfach mal
if you do not have an ssh keypair yet generate one
ok also ssh keygen ssh moment das plötzlich nicht plötzlich in sette ssh key in etc troppe
ach gut key zu das andere ins etc public key und so dass you can as a sign with all the one
you just created and which ends up into the remote machines drop your root key
also es heißt cat.ssh rsazg ganz ganz toll den brauchen wir unbedingt
oder
nehmen wir den da weiß ich auf jeden fall dass der fonds warum auch immer ich den
key hat der set geheißen so das kommt jetzt hier kann auch ein fall vor writing warum
nicht ich sollte vielleicht auch gut werden wenn etc troppe gut
wir machen das jetzt einfach mal
je nach der anleitung at all three
box bevor fall system within the box
ok
also
hooks vor was uns vor dem vor before file systems also net conf job bier und encrypt ssh
ok machen wir also vor fall system aber wenn der sd encrypt steht das bestimmt falsche reihenfolge
net conf
shop bier bier und ein krypt ssh
Confirm the CryptDevice parameter and add... Moment, was? Was will das von mir?
Configure the required CryptDevice parameter and add the IP kernel to your bootloader configuration.
zum Beispiel, wenn du die IP-Adresse für die DHCP-Apps benötigst, kannst du die IP-Parameter benutzen.
Das check ich nicht.
Crypt Device Parameter?
Okay, Kernel Command Line Parameter
das check ich noch.
IP gleich DHCP.
Das check ich noch.
Das muss man wahrscheinlich
in der Limein-Config machen
oder so.
ETC Limein?
Oder wo
macht man das?
etc die falls die mal da hier können hier da ist doch kein command line
okay das rote weiß steht da schon drin anscheinend war jetzt machen wir mal aus
dass wir ordentlich was sehen und das habe gleich dhcp so gut kommt kommt
für die krippe das lassen wir mal gucken was passiert
finally restart remote system and try to ssh
extra ich muss doch moment ich muss doch vorher das neue generieren
ich kann doch jetzt nicht einfach wie star die anleitung ist bis
Arche regenerate binetram fs.
Monsters p.
Okay.
This does not update, let my boot entries use.
Update.
update
was hoch net conf not found
wo sich net conf irgendwie mit installieren
Achso.
NetConf muss ich noch installieren.
Okay.
NetConf.
Boah, das ist wieder Hackerman-Krams, ey.
Was?
System will suspend now?
Wie jetzt?
Wie suspend?
Hat er gedacht, ich bin nicht aktiv und schalte sich jetzt aus, oder was?
Alter.
F.
Hat er sich suspendet.
So, jetzt schalte ich ihn wieder ein.
Das muss ich unbedingt ausschalten mit dem Suspend.
Das ist ja abfuck, ey.
Okay.
Da sind wir wieder hier.
Äh, hallo?
Jetzt ist er wieder da.
Okay, NetConf muss ich installieren.
Äh, gehen wir mal auf die KVM.
und schalten das mal aus.
Wo findet man sowas?
Energy?
Power Management.
Das klingt gut.
When inactive, do nothing.
Apply.
Äh ja.
Do nothing.
Dim automatically, never.
Turn off screen, never.
Gut, perfekt.
Äh, was hat er denn jetzt wieder?
Failed for kernel?
Was, was, was, was, was will er?
Error during build?
Was hat er jetzt?
Hä?
Alter, ist das wieder High-IQ-Shit,
da irgendwas einzurichten?
Arch, by the way.
Was will er denn von mir?
Äh.
Was?
Jetzt müssen wir da noch irgendwie dran rum...
Nein, nein, nein.
Müssen wir da irgendwie dran rumfummeln.
Line, was?
Line 20.
Ne, das da.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste in irgendeiner Art und Weise, was ich hier kann machen.
Ne, ich sag euch nur.
ok es hat aber jetzt funktioniert mal gucken was er jetzt macht beim bei ssh aber ich glaube wir
müssen sd sd encrypt noch ausmachen weil das passt doch irgendwie nicht zusammen aber war reboot
Ja, schauen wir mal.
Meint ihr, das geht jetzt? Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
guck das kommt das kommt davor
das hat so nicht funktioniert ich muss bestimmt sdn kraft rausnehmen
ja muss man bestimmt hier mk etc mk in it things bums hier kommt box
Weil das kommt zuerst.
SD Encrypt.
Dropdeer Arch.
Remote Unlocking Raspberry Pi Running Arch Linux.
Ja perfekt.
Alter, das ist wieder richtiges
High-IQ-Zeug.
Hä?
Jetzt soll man das doch nicht mehr verwenden.
Was? Alter, Leute, wie kompliziert kann man es denn bitteschön machen?
WTF, Alter, ist das kompliziert. Also das ist unter Debian definitiv viel, viel einfacher.
Wie wäre es einfach mal mit einem fucking Guide?
Okay, Partition install... Okay, jetzt hier, jetzt.
Okay.
Set up boot for unlocking encrypted root partition.
I prefer using SD-Encrypt and I copied the hooks from the Arch-Wiki.
Okay.
Chat, verblick dir da durch.
Also, okay.
Also im Prinzip kann ich das alles wieder rausschmeißen, so wie es aussieht.
Aber Moment
Ich hab doch gar kein System D Boot
Oder ist das wieder was anderes
You boot tools
Okay
Also immer was macht.
Also war
Boot CMD Line, aber das brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Das habe ich ja schon gemacht.
Was zum Teufel?
was was zum teufel ist denn jetzt schon bitte schön wieder
sdn krippen
effusion die default at the keyboard as books to
if you so not okay if using business box best and encrypt talks
aber momentan mal ja aber das ist doch gar kein rie
Oh Mann, jetzt ist der Scheiß auch schon wieder
deprecated oder was?
Ey.
Dann machen wir es doch hier.
minimal setup
sd network st tiny ssh ich blick 60 das ist noch nicht das jahr das die
Aber das ist auch ein Wahnsinns-Kram.
Von SystemD-based in het RAMFS.
Ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, dass ich das habe.
Okay?
Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass ich das habe.
Aber jetzt, jetzt, das ist ein Dingspack.
Da muss doch ein...
Einfach neu zu installieren und dann?
Und dann?
Dann habe ich immer noch nicht Remote Unlock.
Also, wir haben es ja schon richtig gemacht.
Also, Leute, irgendwie sagt mir mein Gefühl, ich muss SD encrypt.
weg machen ja ich schreibe das mal dahinter nur für den fall der fälle da
sind funktioniert ja wie mein
regenerate der das überhaupt jetzt
jetzt dieses ding mk mk in it regenerate
Linux.
Gentoo, ja, es wird noch besser.
So, dann machen wir das jetzt nochmal.
Okay, das anscheinend, anscheinend ist das da drin included.
Encrypt SSH?
Yes.
Nochmal.
Okay, jetzt rebooten wir nochmal und gucken mal.
gespannt wie viel wie viel will er noch was macht er da will ja noch alles
regenerate reboot
okay bin ich mal gespannt
Ne.
Oder mal gucken.
Ähm.
Ich guck mal kurz in meinen, ähm,
Router.
Nicht, dass der jetzt doch irgendwas da drin hat.
Server.
Leases.
also das kunst nicht das ist irgendwie
ganze twanziger kram mittlerweile da ssh an lockt auf die reihe zu kriegen
also das von sich gibt da vielleicht ein guide für cash ios ssh an lockt lux
Angeblich hat das SSH drinne, ja.
Arch, SSH, Lux, Unlock.
Muss es doch irgendeinen ordentlichen Guide für geben, Mann.
Letztes Jahr.
Nix, Alter.
Ja, genau.
Ja abt mit dem Jan ist es easy dem Jan habe ich das selbst schon oft erst gemacht
aber chat gpt fragen wie anlocke ich mein btr fs gut über ssh beim guten
Das Ziel ist, dass ich über SSH meine Root-Partition anlocken kann.
Ich hab das auch... Wir haben das auch schon mal im Stream gemacht für Arch, ne? Irgendwann mal.
Das haben wir schon alles installiert.
der klassiker hat der chat gibt es so ein großes gelaber
was habe ich nicht ein reinstalling ist doch alles ist
wofür das dienen soll vielleicht als ablösung zu dieser form hier
statische ip das hat mit start überhaupt nichts zu tun aber sie box kovano installieren
ja ich weiß
drop der muss vor entgrifft kommen ja okay macht es macht es macht es
macht es hier kommt vor in kript oder habe ich irgendwas über übersehen
netcon job bürger in kript ssh
das haben wir auch schon alles gemacht dass das ist auch nachher das problem krab ist halt
Blödsinn.
Encrypt, ja, das
ist aber schon das Richtige. Encrypt SSH.
Also, wir haben's
richtig, aber das Ding startet kein SSH.
Das Ding startet kein SSH
hier, also...
Also, im Prinzip ist das ja sogar richtig,
was chat gpt geschrieben hat aber wie kann ich denn testen ob das überhaupt
greift was ein typo habe ich habe ich nicht
es update ist keine boot entries man es das hier
ip bin ich mir nicht sicher
aber immer so einbauen tut er das
also ich hab ich hab hier diese ich hab die etc
wo habe ich das editiert etc die falls habe ich das hier editiert da habe ich
reingeschrieben ip dhcp also das müsste eigentlich das richtige sein
als wir die mini pc vor vielleicht meine freundin setzen wenn ich die remote ssh
anlockt bekomme was aktuell echt nicht so aussieht weil ich absolut keine ahnung habe
wo es dran hängt
die main change cmd line
Ja, haben wir gemacht.
Haben wir auch gemacht, okay.
Ja, ist da.
Ist da.
kernel parameter an was könnte liegen
Guck mal jetzt, was Google dazu sagt.
Ach Gott.
Okay, so schlau waren wir auch schon.
Ja.
Haben wir auch gemacht.
Ich habe Quiet rausgeschmissen.
was wenn du sd encrypt was zum teufel ist überhaupt sd encrypt man
ok da ok st encrypt ssh unlock sc encrypt over ssh
Was ist denn die Base in der Tram?
Habe ich das überhaupt?
Warum brauche ich ein fucking System D in den Rahmen?
Okay, wir probieren das jetzt mal damit, meinetwegen.
Wollen wir da jetzt noch ewig rummachen?
Das ist ein Our-Package, ne? Also, top.
Moin.
Darf ich mir was wünschen?
Ja, ich wünsche mir, dass mein SSH-Boot
endlich, also die Crypt über SSH
funktioniert.
Ah, in Konflikt.
Remove. Yes.
Drop, ja. Ah, in Konflikt.
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich den Kram removed.
Cannot be found, cannot be found.
Auch weg.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
also leute ich habe keinen plan ich mache das jetzt einfach mal so wie es da steht was soll
ich jetzt machen und da unten drunter sd direkt hier unten drunter soll ich das schreiben oder
es geht heini ssh kommandos alter was also moment ja aber ich will da kein
package für verwenden mensch so ein building des setup copies der
already existing configuration of system den network die from the main system
tries to copy convert existing ssh keys from existing tiny ssh open ssh installation
tiny ssh needs to be okay
okay
die hooks musst du noch anpassen stimmt das muss raus
config.drop.encrypt.ssh kommt raus.
Genau, malware am Start. Hä, glaube ich nicht,
aber ich find's trotzdem doof. Ich will sowas aus den Base-Repos haben für...
sc network wo steht das wo steht hier
kopieren das jetzt einfach mal
was basis im micro mod kommt km s keyboard sd konsolen blog soll ich mal soll ich mal
das nehmen.
Ich spare mir das mal hier.
Runterkopieren.
So.
Plymouth, ist das dieses
Splash-Screen-Ding? Ist das dieses
Splash-Splash-Screen-Gedöns?
Ja, ne?
Okay.
mk inet minus p.
Äh, was?
Invalid? Option?
Was?
Äh, was?
Was hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen, Alter?
Mein Kernel ist weg.
ach so ich bin nicht gut ich kann nur
eine ssh install okay
monka ist das ist kompliziert wie sie aber dem wir alles das super easy
okay was will die file authorize keys das nordic ist ssh keygen ich weiß dass es das nicht generiert
aber das legt das verzeichnis und alles an.
äh, authorizet keys
äh, rsa
jawoll
was?
es muss ein, was muss es sein?
ein ed
Die sind aber echt anstrengend hier.
SSH.
Haben wir hier ein ED?
Papp.
Okay.
Hoblos. Jawohl. Perfekt.
Ich hoffe, der Key stimmt jetzt auch,
den ich da habe.
dieses jahr noch mal durch den schnee gestellt ich bin vor einer woche oder so
aus der durch den schnee gestellt stellst aber ohne was aufzunehmen
wir können auch neue ssh keygen idee aber machen zwar machen wir das so
das ist es kommend wie kann man da noch mal den name angeben
ein blubb ssh keygen name
wie geht man da jetzt nochmal an
Ich will dem Keyfile einen bestimmten Namen geben.
Achso, man kann es direkt eingeben, wie der heißen soll.
Enter file in which the same... Achso.
Achso.
Unlock.
Authorize Keys.
Zack.
Und jetzt.
Gut.
So, und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob es funktioniert.
Erstmal drei Stunden generaten.
Ich fände es halt noch ein bisschen doof, dass das ein Our-Package ist.
Was?
Reusing the host keys from the Rachel Operator.
Geh mal nicht auf den Keks, das juckt mich nicht.
Vielleicht gibt es ja da ein Package.
Weil das ist ein Our-Package, das ist doof.
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja hier irgendwie sowas.
Wenn man danach sucht.
Tut das vielleicht auch?
trotz dass ihr vielleicht auch was für wofür ist das gut
provision tools ist im lh
moment das ist da auch schon drin wtf was
Ich fasse es nicht, warum gibt es 500
Es ist Arch, okay, es ist Arch Linux
Alles ist ja gut, ich weiß ja, aber
500 Varianten, Alter
Das geht, okay, da haben wir schon mal
ein Package, das ist wahrscheinlich meine
bevorzugte Variante jetzt
Aber wir rebooten
jetzt erstmal und gucken, ob das prinzipiell damit
funktionieren würde. Und dann stellen wir das nochmal um.
Brage, Leute.
Brage, Brage. Massive Brage.
Hyper Brage.
Moment, gibt's das?
Hyper
Brage.
Das Remote gibt's doch nicht, Leute.
Witzbar Zeit. Hyper Brage.
Reboot.
Wenn man weiß, wie es geht, ist es am Ende wahrscheinlich ganz einfach.
Ja, ja, Enter.
Aha!
Please enter passphrase for this code.
Äh.
Und hat er jetzt...
Okay.
Aber SSH ist immer noch nicht oben.
Ja, was soll ich denn sonst noch machen?
Nee.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt hier mit.
Ah, andere IP bekommen.
Du hast recht.
Ich hätte gucken sollen.
Aber der müsste normalerweise doch auch was raushauen auf der Command Line.
Nee.
Andere IP gab es auch nicht.
Nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt hier mit.
Also, ups.
SSH.
Nicht Debian.
Äh.
Max.
Dokumentierst du das dann am Ende?
Natürlich, natürlich.
Was sonst?
Ich hab den Stream immer schief, dann weiß man Bescheid.
Okay, dann bauen wir das jetzt nochmal aus.
Alles klar?
wir installieren jetzt diesen kraft also hier minus ssh minus rmk in it system de extras
ja hoax not found nervt nicht rum
ok so und jetzt system die tool activate required hooks nach system
demo sich direkt system die tool hinschreiben ok
Port offen?
Naja, das ist ja das Ding.
Der chartet ja kein SSH.
Das ist...
ETC, MK,
Init,
Conf.
So, hier, direkt
danach soll das hin.
Ich finde schon mal gut, dass das vorne
steht.
Das machen wir mal weg.
Guck mal, wie es weiter...
Oh fuck, ich hab das schon wieder nicht als...
Doch, hab ich.
So.
Configurable Enable Disable Provide
for example for remote unlocking
of Lux Root with Crypt Setup
and Tiny SSH.
Edit.
Kann man das da reinpasten?
Ist das Edit?
Gott sei Dank, gibt's doch nicht.
Äh.
Äh, äh, äh.
was was was was zum was was will er von mir
zumindest war zumindest ein ssh müsste aufgehen
ok system die enable
enable enable enable bild image review content finally reboot
das ist ja schon mal gut
ach linux cache heißt das dann
ok wir machen langsam minus v kommt mal weg
was was was in valence aus bayeri was
ist das mit night commander warum warum warum brauche ich mein mitleid commander alter
ok
Passende Musik, ja.
Der.
Ist ja grausam, ey.
Und geht's jetzt,
Boss Champ?
Okay.
Yes.
Und dann soll ich das da machen?
Okay, was auch immer.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen zum richtigen Einrichten
dann noch einen zweiten Stream.
Das heißt, jetzt fordern, wenn ihr dabei sein wollt.
Kleiner Sellout-Modus.
Weil das ist ja schon wieder echt grausam.
Wir hängen jetzt schon seit über einer Stunde
an Remote SSH-Unlock.
Und das brauche ich!
Ich will doch nicht jedes Mal meine Tastatur umstöpseln,
um das Ding hochfahren zu können.
Das geht nicht ohne.
Image.
Okay.
Das ist nicht nur wegen Loks, ja?
Okay, jetzt haben wir es, würde ich sagen.
Reboot.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob der jetzt endlich mal SSH und einen DHCP-Gramm macht.
Ich guck mal in meinen Router.
Ja, booten wir mal.
Ja.
Da stand irgendwas von Secret gerade.
Ah!
Alter!
1, 2, 1 hat der jetzt für eine IP.
Äh, als was muss man sich da hinordnen?
Gut.
Äh.
Moment.
SSH minus I.
SSH.
Unlock.
Ah.
Chat. Das sieht gut aus.
Es hat funktioniert.
Was ein Act, Mann.
Was ein Act.
Alter.
easy alles war komplett easy komplett easy easy easy um nicht zu sagen
so und wir haben es mit offiziellen packages hingekriegt ja mit offiziellen
packages perfekt meine fresse jetzt kann man weitermachen
wir haben remote ssh anloggt sehr gut sehr gut weiß dass das schreddert mir
nicht dass gut dass der kampf das wird er mir nicht schreddern weil wir haben
es jetzt sagen wir halbwegs offiziell gemacht
ssh copy id
alter was nimmst du für einen dummen key
alter unlockpub du sollst mal einen ordentlichen key nehmen
ssh copy id ssh nehmen den da
Wo findest du mein Fixed SSH? Das gibt es nirgendswo, aber das ist
iiq-shell-magic. Guck mal hier, das macht das Fixed SSH. Fixed SSH holt sich aus dem Terminal
den kompletten Text, greppt dort nach dem Fehler von SSH, holt sich dann die IP raus vom letzten
ssh kommando für damit ssh keygen minus er auslöscht es aus allen ssh falls und
dann und dann holt sich aus der history den letzten ssh befehl und führt er
noch mal aus das nice oder
schitt ab gut okay jetzt kann ordentlich was machen jetzt jetzt habe ich okay
Als nächstes Chat Tastatur und Maus-Sharing.
Tastatur und Maus-Sharing.
Und dann kann ich auch einen Monitor dran anschließen.
Wie installiert man unter CacheOS Packages Package?
Warum ich das mache?
Vielleicht um meine Linux-VRM abzulösen.
wie ist das ding des flow guck mal hier gibt es auch
Man muss ja wirklich in dem
Okay, ehrlich gesagt, dann kann ich es auch
Über die Shell installieren
Wenn ich jetzt sogar noch Yes drücken muss
Hier drinnen, das ist ja quasi
Ein Terminal im Extrafenster
Das ist ja dumm
Da mach ich das gleich weiter
Okay, Desk
Low
No thanks.
Also hier, die IP brauchen wir.
1, 3, 4.
Make this computer client.
Connect.
Yes.
Share.
Was?
Wie?
Nee, du bist doch connected.
Was laberst du denn?
Du bist doch connected.
Nee, was?
Failed connect to server?
Windows stellen, Salda.
Server refused client with our name.
Achso, das muss ich noch machen.
Okay.
Cache US ist auf der linken Seite.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Has connected.
Äh, ja, okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen doof, weil jetzt sehe ich es nicht.
Aber es scheint zu funktionieren.
Es scheint zu funktionieren.
Wir gucken mal, ob es funktioniert.
Wenn ich jetzt hier nämlich rausgehe und jetzt hier wieder zurück, dann ist es hier offen.
Okay, Mouse Sharing funktioniert.
Dann wird es Zeit für...
Ah, ne, Moment, Autostart von dem Ding brauchen wir noch.
Autostart.
Probier mal Clipboard.
Erinnere mich gleich nochmal dran.
Ich will jetzt erstmal hier den Kram neu...
Desk
Flow
So, ich will das jetzt einmal nochmal ordentlich ausprobieren.
Also.
Ich restart jetzt.
Restart.
Also gehen wir mal von aus.
Ich starte jetzt mein Computer.
Ohne jetzt hier
mein
KVM dran zu haben.
Computer wird gestartet.
Dann muss ich SSH
anlocken.
hoffentlich wieder die 121 wo ich mir die ip dann raussuchen und so was das ist ein
bisschen ätzend aber okay geht alles von alleine soweit das ist wayland also die
kde läuft unter wayland ja okay es wäre natürlich sinnvoll wenn er jetzt hier noch eine ip schreiben
oder ssh
auf es ist wieder eine andere ip mann
das wird abfakt das weiß ich jetzt schon
jetzt ist es die 132
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Unlocken wir jetzt.
Genau.
Jetzt bootet der Mist.
Und sollte direkt da reinbooten.
Mich anmelden und gleich
das Maus-Sharing starten.
Okay, Funst. Nice.
Okay, sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Dann können wir das hier zumachen.
Äh, Moment.
Ich schalte nochmal aus.
Power off.
Okay, Solo, Power off.
Ja, ist gut.
So.
Jetzt fährt er sich runter und jetzt schließe ich das Ding mal an der Capture Card an.
Kannst du den Router nicht festmachen?
Doch, doch kann ich.
doch ist es aus also machen wir das hier ab ab netzwerk kabel ab strom kann dran bleiben ich
muss immer umstecken hier jetzt mal hier rüber auf dem schreibtisch
tisch
so jetzt stöpseln wir mal hier
ich weiß immer mein headset zeug runter also war damals strom habe ich dran
netzwerkkabel ist auch jetzt brauchen wir die
Jetzt brauchen wir die Capture Card.
Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz Headset weg.
Capture Card.
Und?
Display Port brauchen wir vom Monitor.
ok so ich glaube jetzt habe ich alles dran netzwerk kabel ok jetzt machen wir mal an
dazu müssen jetzt erstmal die elgato capture card hier hinzufügen video capture device
nämlich kamo game capture hd vielleicht aha vielleicht soll ich mal anschalten
schalten.
Achso, das ist die. Okay, das suckt.
Habe ich jetzt überhaupt...
Warum captchert meine Elgato nichts?
Habe ich die richtige?
Ja.
Eigentlich schon.
Ah, Moment, da zeigt doch da
was an gerade.
Machen wir das mal kurz weg.
Kopieren wir das.
Machen wir das an.
was ist für eine bescheuerte auflösung chat ist
wo ich den chat nämlich hier aufmachen dass ich noch was sehe gleich weil ich
wo am anderen bildschirm nichts mehr nichts mehr habe in der richtung so
iphone das braucht man nicht
video capture device
resolution ja was auch immer okay chat jetzt seht ihr was oder jetzt müsst ihr den kram sehen
jetzt mache ich ssh unlock das natürlich wieder das ist abfackelnd so jetzt unlock ich den krempel
Ist das klein?
Ihr müsstet eigentlich jetzt ganz gut Fullscreen was sehen.
Guck mal hier.
Hallo, Chat.
Okay, und jetzt...
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz was gucken.
Ich muss jetzt sagen, Display Configuration.
Hier.
Display Configuration.
Und dann kann man hier Replica Off.
Ne, umgedreht.
Umgedreht.
Elgato.
Replica Off.
Eben da.
Keep.
So.
Und jetzt seht ihr das gleiche, was ich auch sehe.
Ja. Und ich hab meine Maus
geshared. Und ich hab's jetzt auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Okay, gut.
Excellent.
So, und jetzt testen wir mal.
Copy, paste. Chat. Copy, paste.
Geht nicht.
Das war ja klar.
Wayland-Stelz. Das war ja klar,
dass das nicht funktioniert.
Das war so
klar.
Wobblons.tv
Moment, als erstes hier
erste Mal.
Ähm.
U-Block Origin, Firefox.
Nicht Unlock. U-Block Origin.
Warum steht man
Firefox auf Deutsch? Das muss schon
gleich mal weg.
Add.
Okay.
Sieht man den Chat
auch noch unten im Fenster alles?
So.
Oblos TV.
Nicht?
Kein Chatke? Sekunde.
Ah.
Ah, okay. Jetzt Chatke, ne?
Jetzt Chatke da.
jetzt chat
was hat er den ukrainian research gegeben dass wir als bestellt habe
So, und jetzt machen wir hier mal den Chat auf.
Chat.
Nervt nicht rum hier mit dem Zeug.
Pop-out-Chat.
Okay.
Chat, da sind wir.
Ich habe noch kein ffz ins zfz firefox wichtigste muss ja noch
Wichtigste überhaupt franker phases z
Ffz
Jetzt hier addons
Enable
Enable.
Gut.
Chat, probiert mal irgendein Emote aus, ob es funktioniert.
Irgendwas, was nicht Standard Twitch Emote ist.
Okay, Dentke.
Wenn Dentke funktioniert, dann ist alles gut.
So.
Kann man CacheOS look like Windows machen?
Bestimmt.
Aber die Frage ist, will man das?
Also ich würde es nicht wollen.
Aber das kann man bestimmt machen.
KDE ist super customizable.
So, wie kriege ich denn jetzt...
Wie kriege ich jetzt mein Clipboard geshared?
Ach, Moment, Moment, Moment mal.
In die Richtung geht es?
Nee, oder?
Wartet mal.
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Nee, es geht in keine der drei beiden Richtungen.
Kann man auch machen.
Es geht in keine Richtung.
So, dann müssen wir jetzt erstmal hier suchen.
Ähm.
Desk Flow.
Erstmal müssen wir was anderes machen.
Erstmal müssen wir meine Language umstellen.
Ne, ist doch hier.
Browser Englisch.
Ja.
Okay, dann weiß ich nicht, was er hat.
Okay, also jetzt hier
Deskflow, Wayland,
Clipboard.
Wetten das jetzt nicht Support oder geht wieder nicht?
Geolocation
muss ausgestellt werden.
Clipboard Support.
Aha.
Lass mich raten, das geht wieder nicht.
Och man.
Alter Wayland, warum gehen da immer
diese Basic Sachen nicht?
Clipboard, brauchen wir nicht.
Das regt mich schon wieder auf.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt mit Maus- und Tastatursharing vielleicht nicht der allerbasigste Fall, aber man will es trotzdem haben.
Gibt es da schon ein Patch für?
Okay, das ist abfuck.
Ich hab ne Idee.
Können wir nicht KDE Connect verwenden
für Clipboard-Sharing?
Ging das nicht irgendwie?
KDE Connect?
Für Clipboard?
Das ging doch, oder?
Aber nur, aber Moment, aber nicht mit Windows, oder?
Mit Windows geht das auch?
Und wie?
Windows geht, okay, wie würde ich das jetzt miteinander verbinden?
Wie genau? Wie genau verbinde ich jetzt hier Sachen miteinander?
Einfach KDE Connect unter Windows installieren
Okay
Dann wollen wir mal
KDE Connect Windows
Download
Ja, ja, gib mir lieber den Installer
Oh, das sieht ja oldschool aus.
Finish.
Okay, und jetzt?
Und jetzt?
K.D.
Connect.
Hallo?
Warte.
Die läuft.
Und wo läuft...
Ah, die braucht einfach nur ewig.
So.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt habe ich die auf beiden installiert.
Und ich sehe die Devices nicht.
Die Rechner stehen im gleichen Netz direkt nebeneinander.
Hat den Kram schon mal irgendjemand benutzt?
Keine Ahnung, wie das Funks war.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht...
Firewall?
Ah, du meinst auf der Linux-Seite?
Okay, ich mache auf der Linux-Seite einfach mal...
ich mache auf der linux seite mal die firewall aus
ich mache einfach mal die firewall aus
Enabled, zack
Okay, ist es disabled?
Ah
Jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Okay.
Use device as external monitor.
Achso.
Okay, und
syncht es jetzt Clipboard automatisch schon?
Ja
Macht es
Kunst
Clipboard Share
Nice
Okay, das ist in der Tat gar nicht mal so schlecht jetzt.
So, jetzt muss ich mal was gucken.
Jetzt machen wir mal ein YouTube-Video von mir auf.
Schauen wir mal ein YouTube-Video von mir auf.
und
ja genau das hier, gut da bewegt sich ein bisschen was
ja gut Sound haben wir jetzt natürlich nicht
ähm
jetzt schalten wir das Ding mal
auf
1044p
60fps
sieht ganz brauchbar aus
oh
haben wir kein Sound
Weil
Ich den Sound in OBS nicht eingeschaltet hab
Von der Capture Card
Und der Sound würde eh ein bisschen laggen
So, was ich jetzt eigentlich gucken wollte
Ist folgendes
NV Top
Okay, die Grafikkarte macht ein bisschen was
GPU
Also das ist auf jeden Fall
auf jeden fall gpu decoded würde ich sagen oder was mein dir ja sieben prozent gibt also ich
würde sagen dass es g plus c das heißt graphic plus computer würde ich sagen das ist gpu decoded
gpu 43 prozent und wenn man das ausmacht ist es dann bedeutend weniger ja ja ja ja auf jeden
fall ja ja ok also das ist gpu decode hier kommt mal ein kt code das ist das ist hardware decoding
Artfertig Coding.
Okay, nice.
So, dann
würde ich sagen, machen wir das
gerade nochmal ein bisschen ordentlich.
Und zwar, also was brauchen
wir denn?
Kann man,
startet KDE Connect eigentlich jetzt automatisch?
Oh Mist.
Startet es?
Weather Report?
What?
Okay.
Was ich eigentlich machen wollte, ist Autostart KDE Connect.
Ja.
Application KDE Connect.
Ja, das soll gefälligst Auto starten.
So, und das schmeißen wir aus dem Autostart wieder raus.
So, also was wir jetzt auf jeden Fall noch machen ist,
ich installiere mir ein gescheites Terminal.
Western.
So.
Und dafür, dass ihr hier was seht,
machen wir das mal wieder weg.
Ich logge mich per SSH nochmal auf der Kiste ein hier.
ich sehe mich gerade mal hier drüber ein bisschen ordentlich das terminal habe so und da kopieren
wir jetzt rüber also ich starte west herrmann gut über ssh geht es natürlich nicht western
seht ihr jetzt nicht aber es ist gestartet so jetzt kopieren wir nämlich ein paar sachen
rüber. Also, wir machen jetzt erstmal
ZSH installieren.
Ist install, okay.
Does this look like a diamond?
What? Nein!
This is power level
2K configuration with that. Ich will den
Kram nicht.
Okay, wir sagen einfach mal
yes.
Yes.
was ist dauer pointing at one
dualis icons fit between the crosses
ich will eben eine eigene zsh pure pure ist beste
right 24 7 auf jeden fall zwei zeilig
chat ich sehe den unterschied nicht was ist der unterschied zwischen
ach so der abstand kompakt enable trends prompt
ich erkenne unterschiedlich yes ok
Instant Prompt Mode. Ich habe kein Plastenschirm aus Instant Prompt Mode. Yes.
Laggy ist das. Laggy.
Sieht ja fast schon ein bisschen aus wie... Uhhh, FZF, Monk, HS, Alter.
ok dann werden wir jetzt mal folgendes machen copy zsh rc
jetzt was habe ich jetzt gemacht
ob die zsh rc dahin
sucht feierlich starship muss installieren da ship den ober braucht den dino
Power Level 10k, schon lange tot ist es das?
Zwei Wochen, letztes Update.
Nö, anscheinend nicht, aber ich will das gar nicht benutzen.
Ich benutze eh meine eigene Shell-Config.
ok also den rot das kann ich raus schmeißen das blut sich immer
was ist drin
den vm champ den kann man auch raus schmeißen da cube ctl installieren wir nachher
da ist
was da schon bis zur gleich noch konfigurieren ist der blick aber sie haben vor zwei wochen
ein neues comment neues neues comet gehabt so wo ist wo ist die starship config starship starship
Toml, okay.
Config.
Ah.
Das ist doch schon viel besser, Leute.
Jetzt haben wir hier unseren gescheiten Prompt.
Jetzt wissen wir zwar nicht mehr,
wo wir drauf sind, weil es sich so ähnlich sieht.
Aber jetzt schon viel besser.
Gubctl installieren wir auch.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt kann man das hier nämlich ausloggen
und hier wieder umschalten auf
die Geschichte.
Also im Moment
Westterm. Westterm Conf müssen wir noch
machen. Westterm Conf.
Sekunde, ich kopiere das gerade mal rüber.
SCP.
scp config hat man gleich west western western western gibt es nicht okay
mkdir
config
western
ok, so, jetzt haben wir es
das ist caching
so, jetzt haben wir es, jetzt gucken wir es hier
western
da sind wir
bam
ok, eine
blöde Sache
ich komme ja von einem Tiling Window Manager
eine blöde Sache
Ich habe keine Fensterrahmen eingeschaltet.
Weil, wozu?
Bei einem Teil-Renal Manager braucht man das nicht.
Jetzt habe ich keine Fensterrahmen.
Ich meine, es gibt Schlimmeres, oder?
Als keine Fensterrahmen.
alle leute bei recht viele da heute
kurz in der config ändern ich will nämlich ich will nämlich auch mal teilen window manager
ausprobieren hier ich will die ganze zeit aber das machen wir heute nicht das raucht
mir der Kopf. Mango-WC
wollte ich mal ausbrennen. Mango-WC.
Wie gesagt, ich bin ja Tiling-Window-Manager-Fan.
Und das Ding wollte ich mal
ausbrennen. Leute, ich habe die wichtigste
Sache vergessen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Machen immer noch. Chat, ihr wisst, was ich vergessen
habe, oder?
Sollte klar sein.
Chat, wer weiß es?
Was habe ich vergessen?
Wichtigstes Feature ever? Wobbly-Windows.
Korrekt.
geht ganz okay effekt desktop effekt
wap windows apply
das beste feature
Wobbel, wobbel, wobbel.
Ja, Körse, guck, so vergrößert sich der Körser.
Wenn man ihn schüttelt.
Kein Screen Tearing.
Wobbel, Wobbel.
Wichtigste Sache hier.
Wobbly Windows.
Jetzt bin ich zufrieden.
Endlich habe ich wieder Wobbelfenster.
wobbelfenster ordentliche shell mit einem ordentlichen terminal so kann man wenigstens
wieder arbeiten ich glaube die richtige schrift art habe ich noch nicht ganz habe ich hack von
installiert heck und heck nee aber der hat einen guten fall weg von der schriftart was ist das
für die was ist das für eine schriftart hier weil ich habe config western krebs die fonds
was benutzt der hier heck und wie moji benutzt ja und heck ist auf jeden fall nicht installiert wie
Fimoji bestimmt auch nicht, oder?
Emoji Selector.
Okay, doch.
Es ist ein Emoji-Font installiert.
Aber ich weiß nicht, welcher.
Welcher Emoji-Font ist denn das?
Das ist nicht Fimoji, ne?
Fimoji sieht anders aus.
Was sind das für welche?
Noto Fonz Emoji.
Okay, Google Dinger sind das.
Ja.
Tweetmoji ist mir tatsächlich lieber.
Tweetmoji sind die Twitter Emojis.
Die mittlerweile nicht mehr von Twitter
zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Die haben jetzt eigene Emojis gebaut.
leute die früher bei twitter gearbeitet haben aber ich meine damit kann man
jetzt schon mal halbwegs leben hier und screen terminal zack sondern die frage
ist okay wie machen wir jetzt wir machen das mal anders wie machen wir denn jetzt
überhaupt mehrere desktops virtual desktops weil ich will das terminal im
fullscreen auf dem zweiten bildschirm haben ja nicht hier beim browser
Wie macht man virtuelle Desktops?
Add or manage widgets.
Hä?
Was?
Das erinnert mich an Windows.
Bloß nicht ganz so schlimm.
Exit?
Workspaces.
Virtual Desktops.
Desktop 1, Desktop 2.
desktop
jetzt hat mir was zum switchen okay und jetzt muss ich nur noch einstellen
was wir brauchen wir hier haben wir vier desktops
und ja sehe ich auch so und die nächste frage die sich mir hier stellt ist
wie
wie macht man da jetzt die shortcuts für
für desktop switchen
wenn du willst du bist irgendwo unter shortcuts
das habe ich das letzte mal schon mal gesucht
window management
alles hier
switch switch to desktop 1
er das problem hat
also kann die es echt ganz angenehm muss man echt sagen kannst nix
moment zu desktop 3
ok von der top 2 habe ich verkackt
ja von heißt ich kann jetzt im endeffekt man weiß zu machen und sagen hier western
java full screen das ist schon fast so wie beim teiling manager
das geht das geht eigentlich voll klar mit kd
Vielleicht bleib... Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Ich glaube, ich bleib einfach bei KDE.
Das ist kein kleines Projekt.
Das benutzen viele.
Das ist morgen nicht mehr supported.
Ja, die Animationen sind tatsächlich
jetzt auch nicht unbedingt mein Fall.
Aber ich muss mir erstmal überlegen,
wie ich das...
Guckt ihr mal die Taskbar an.
Was soll ich mir da angucken?
Meta T?
Aha!
Was bin ich hier jetzt sehend?
Äh.
Was ist das?
wieso geht ihr im zweiten desktop nach oben macht sie gar nicht
remote unlock ist super easy mit dem passenden paket eine ein
paket installieren und zwei sachen da eintragen
Tiling Zones, wie du mit
Meta-Shift-Links-Klick auf ein Fenster
zuweisen kannst. Also es heißt...
Okay, okay.
Geh mal von aus, ich hab jetzt zweimal West Term offen.
Und jetzt mach ich was?
Ctrl-T?
Split?
Ich check's aber nicht,
was das hier macht.
Ehrlich gesagt.
ich das kapiere ich nicht und jetzt das check ich nicht was macht das jetzt
meta t definiert die zonen okay
Habe ich hier unten eigentlich bei mir auch so ein Plus?
Ja, habe ich.
Meta-Shift-Links-Klick.
okay ich da bin damit damit zu dumm übrigens noch was was was ich jetzt schon
sehe was mich an weiland wieder abfuckt seht ihr es auch seht ihr es auch chat
wer sieht's auch wer sieht's auch
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Seht ihr es?
Keiner sieht es, oder?
Wenn ich hier markiere,
ist es kein Textcursor,
sondern normaler Mauscursor.
Und der Mauscursor ändert sich hier zwischen.
Heißt das, dass Westterm nicht im Wayland-Modus läuft?
Oder wie ist das?
Westterm? Guck mal mal.
Westterm, Lua.
Bond.
End.
Aber ich konfiguriere gar nichts großartig.
ok west wie geht das mit westerm wayland enable wayland aha
der default ist true
Okay, wir setzen das jetzt mal auf true
Auch wenn das damit nichts zu tun haben sollte
Ist das eine GTK App?
Weiß ich nicht
Ist es das?
Oh
Sekunde, ich hab irgendwas verkackt
Jetzt ist mein Terminal kaputt, geil
Moment
Gut, dass ich noch ein anderes Terminal hab
Das war ein Colors Block, ja
Config
West Term
Ups
Hier drunter muss das
Best Term
Aber guck mal
Der Mauszeiger ist anders
Zwischen KDE und dem Terminal
Das ist schon ein bisschen
Abfuck unter Wayland alles
So und jetzt machen wir mal was
jetzt ob es gehen wir mal hier rein und sagen in ebola falls und dann mal gucken was passiert
du kannst ein gtk team ändern die sollen wir mal einfach nicht auf den zack gehen mit irgendwelchen
teams das soll einfach funktionieren wenn man es wenn man will dass er sofort funktioniert
Ist auch geil, Alter.
Sofort funktioniert's.
Mauszeiger, Cursor,
einfach Well and Disabled.
Toll, oder?
Also mit X-Emulation gleich alles wieder viel besser.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, der Mauszeiger
gefällt mir halt überhaupt nicht.
cursor wie kann man den cursor ändern kurs am liebsten hätte ich die kurs aus du magst
weil er lieber als x11 magst du auch dass deine anwendungen gescheit funktionieren sowie zum
beispiel richtigen mauszeiger haben oder ein textblock es ist ja nach wie vor weil es ist
nur x in wayland und das funktioniert anscheinend besser weil die funktion
alle anwendungen haste glück mein terminal hat probleme mit der maus
cursor und hier den dem anderen cursor was ist das eigentlich für komisches ls
was ich hier benutze warum seit wann chat seit wann kann ls icons ist das das
original ls oder es ist ein fake ls
Das ist ein Fake-LS, hä?
Also EZA ist es...
Ist es nicht, ist aber auch installiert.
Was ist das für ein komisches LS? Das gefällt mir nämlich nicht.
man fein mit dem ort schämen namen
touch und txt
wir haben es ist er sah es
Es ist...
Okay, das...
Okay.
Das finde ich aber schon mal
nicht gut, dass LS da irgendwie
intern...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Das ist nix.
Das ist wirklich nix.
Ich will ein ganz normales LS haben, wo ich dann sowas hier machen kann, zum Beispiel.
Ach jetzt hat es funktioniert, okay.
Ach hier, hier ist jetzt ein ganz normales LS. Das wäre eine Fischshell Magic gewesen.
ok ok wie war das noch mal change shell
chat ge bloggen irgendwie schön schell login wie ging das noch mal
die stelle sagt er benutzt das auch fisch ändern user bin
Zerrsa.
Shell changed.
Okay, zack.
Muss ich dazu neu starten?
Ne.
Exzellent.
Ja, das gefällt mir jetzt schon wieder besser.
naja wirklich gut funktioniert das noch nicht hat man ja gerade gesehen aber so
kann ich damit leben was wünscht es jetzt auch aufs aha okay das wird schon auch durch die
desktops oder nicht moment habe ich chat ich bin bin verwirrt ich habe hier das noch mal
offen so ok animation muss noch weg findet ihr okay was gibt's animation
es ist halt ein kdl kannst 30.000 sachen einstellen
Virtual Desktop Switching.
Slide, Fade.
Ich finde, Fade ist gar nicht mal so übel, oder?
Aber ganz ehrlich,
nein, ist wahrscheinlich echt besser.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ist schon besser.
Würde ich sagen, ja, ohne Animation ist schon besser.
meistens laufen die probleme auf fehlerhafte wayland implementation der programme hinaus
das mag streng genommen zu sein aber kennst du die story von gpu decoding unter linux im
browser gpu decoding von videos unter linux im browser hat keine ahnung zehn
jahre länger gedauert als unter anderen plattformen warum weil sie sich 30.000
warum gestreitet gestritten haben ob das jetzt das problem vom browser ist das
problem von den mesatreibern das problem von den grafiker das problem von den
grafikkarten erstellen das problem von linux selbst was auch immer ganz ehrlich
dieses ganze hin und her der scheiß muss es ist mir vollkommen egal der scheiß
muss funktionieren
wenn ich dann so dinge habe wie copy paste geht einfach nicht es sind so
dinge es ist mir scheißegal warum copy paste nicht geht ich will auch nicht
irgendwelche sachen von github laden patch neu kompilieren dass es vielleicht
funktioniert also basic sachen will ich dass die funktionieren und ja das mag so
sein dass das ein problem ist aber anscheinend wenn es so viele fehler
hafte fehlerhafte implementierung gibt dann sollte man sich vielleicht mal
überlegen ob es nicht erstens unnötig kompliziert ist ja oder vielleicht
einfach nicht alle features gibt die man braucht
Und ich glaube beides hast du bei Wayland.
Du hast auch coole andere Sachen.
So ist es nicht.
Jetzt sind nicht alle schlecht.
Copy-Paste geht nicht.
Nee.
Copy-Paste ging bei mir nicht.
Ich benutze aber auch ein bisschen advancedere Variante.
Nämlich ich benutze die Maus und Tastatur von meinem anderen Rechner hier an der Linux-Kiste.
Ja also sprich wenn ich hier einen rechten mauszeilen
Rest bildschirm rechten bildschirm haben wir aus dann springt darüber auf man anderen bildschirm den jetzt nicht seht also hier guck ich zeige euch
Mal die andere seite
guck hier so hier ist jetzt ist er wieder rüber bei linux
und
Damit funktioniert copy paste nicht zwischen windows und linux
Das ist mit desk flow ist das
das ist wohl irgendein barrier oder synergy fork aber halbwegs moderner und das gleiche problem
hast du wenn du es unter vmware benutzt da kann geht copy paste auch nicht richtig vom host in
die vm das sind halt so dinge das mag an irgendwelchen stellen das mag an vmware liegen
es mag an irgendwelchen inkompatiblen sachen liegen irgendwelche wlan spezifikation was auch
immer. Aber ganz ehrlich, Copy-Paste-
Probleme gab es nie
mit X.
Wie gesagt, dafür hatte X andere Probleme.
Das ist keine Frage. Aber ich denke mal
so Basic-Dinger, die
teilweise irgendwie nach 15 Jahren immer
noch nicht funktionieren. Weil Wayland ist ja auch alt.
Es ist ja nicht, dass Wayland was Neues wäre.
Ja, ich weiß.
Allein schon, dass man solche Diskussionen
überhaupt führen muss darüber.
Ja?
Es gibt jetzt 18 verschiedene Copy-Paste-Implementierungen.
Oder was? Das ist so...
Macht es so unnötig, wir einfach.
Ja und okay, mag sein.
Aber es ist doch für mich als Anwender vollkommen egal, bei wem das Problem letztendlich liegt.
So Basic-Sachen wie Copy-Paste, das sollte einfach funktionieren.
Du hast ja auch schon so Probleme bei Wayland mit irgendwelchen Overlay-Fenstern.
Oder mit Fenster-Automatisierung zum Beispiel.
Versuch mal unter Wayland das gleiche zu machen wie mit XdoTools.
Kennt ihr XdoTools?
So, X2 Tools.
Damit kann man, hier, Key N, seht ihr das?
Damit kann man Sachen schicken an andere Fenster, ja?
Zum Beispiel Key Press N, wie ihr hier seht, ja?
Der drückt jetzt N in meinem Terminal.
Ich könnte es aber auch an andere Fenster senden.
Macht das mal unter Wayland.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es da überhaupt einen Weg gibt.
Auch mit ganz vielen Hacks.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gibt, das überhaupt zu machen.
Gibt es X-Tool...
Okay, wir gucken jetzt einfach mal.
X-Tool Wayland.
Sind wir noch ein bisschen besser?
X-Tool für Wayland.
Gibt es wahrscheinlich einfach nicht.
W-Type.
Okay, es funktioniert mit Wayland-Kompetenzen, die das Virtual-Tastatur-Protokoll unterstützen.
Ja, genau, Sunray, exakt das ist es.
Die letzten Jahre tut sich da einiges, ja.
Wir haben ja Wayland immer mal wieder hier im Stream angeguckt.
Und ich weiß noch, als ich relativ neu auf Twitch war,
da hatten wir das Problem...
Die ist jetzt absichtlich im Hintergrund aufgegangen.
Da hatten wir das Problem unter Wayland,
dass wenn man ein Fenster aufgemacht hat,
muss man sich mal vorstellen, man hat ein Fenster...
Das ist ja nicht wie in Wayland, ne?
Man hat ein Fenster unter Wayland aufgemacht,
das muss ein paar Jahre her sein.
als ich hier auf Twitch angefangen habe.
Weiß nicht, wann das war.
2020 oder so.
Also ist schon ein bisschen her.
Wenn man da unter Wayland eine Anwendung
resized hat
und die Anwendung irgendwas nicht richtig
implementiert hat oder whatever,
dann hat es nicht so resized
wie hier, ja, den Inhalt
resized, äh, den Content
resized. Es hat den gesamten Inhalt
resized. Die Auflösung blieb gleich
und ist einfach nur alles größer geworden.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, Wayland ist ja nicht alt
Ist ja nicht neu, Wayland ist alt
Aber du hast voll und ganz recht
Sano, jetzt sehe ich ganz genau so
Das hat sich erst die letzten Jahre einiges getan
Da machen die einen Riesenakt
Und wenn ich das schon lese
Dass die bei Deskflow
Copy-Paste unterstützen wollen
Dass die irgendwie erst eine Protokoll
Portalspezifikation
Oder irgendwas schreiben müssen
Whatever
das copy paste hier in ihrem screen sharing oder mousetrading tastatur sharing tool funktioniert
es ist schon ein bisschen alles aber letztendlich der grund der grund warum ich jetzt auch sage ich
gehe jetzt auf weyland und ich x ist es ist ja am horizont zu sehen also erkennt also x hat probleme
Ja, das ist keine Frage. Und mit neuen Features oder irgendwelchem Support, also kannst du bei X eh vergessen.
Und ich denke halt auch, dass X immer weiter ausgefaced wird über die nächsten Jahre.
Ja, X wird es immer noch geben, aber bald ist es nicht mehr standardmäßig dabei.
Dann gibt es irgendwelche extra Repos, irgendwelche Sachen sind nicht mehr mit X-Bildflex gebaut, dass es dann nicht mehr mit X funktioniert.
Das wird so ein schleichender Prozess sein, dass X immer weiter sich so outfacet.
Deswegen dachte ich mir, ey, jetzt ist Wayland gerade in einem Zustand, wo man sagen kann, es ist semi-gut benutzbar und da kann man sich jetzt schon mal drauf einstellen.
Es wird eher noch besser die nächsten Jahre.
Ja, aber ich meine so Sachen wie, dass mein Mauszeiger zwischen zwei Fenstern unterschiedlich ist und mich hier das Select-Icon anzeigt, sowas ist halt schon ein bisschen der Witz.
Und dass es dann erst funktioniert, wenn Wayland deaktiviert ist.
Ja, es ist standardisiert, nur dass es irgendwie 18 verschiedene Implementierungen dann gibt.
Mit unterschiedlichen Unzulänglichkeiten wahrscheinlich.
Genauso wie Screen Recording und sowas.
Also da gibt es schon noch einige Probleme.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen denke ich schon,
dass
der Weg auch in der Zukunft
ist, weil X wird es eh nicht mehr werden
und was anderes gibt es nicht.
Schade eigentlich, ne?
Dass es nicht irgendwas
Gescheites gibt.
Aber vielleicht wird Wayland noch gescheit
über die nächsten paar Jahre.
Ist ja schon deutlich besser geworden.
Ja, hast du mal Screen Recording
beispielsweise unter Sway probiert oder sowas?
Mal gucken, ob das mittlerweile geht.
Waylands, Sway.
Sway, Screen
Recording.
Easy Way.
Okay.
WF Recorder.
Das scheint...
Ich meine, immerhin gibt es da anscheinend Sachen.
Wie sieht es mit Teams-Screensharing unter Wayland aus?
Geht das mittlerweile?
Can capture screen in Sway.
Ja, solche Dinger.
Ja, geht das?
Das ist schön, dass das tut.
Das war nämlich auch längere Zeit Probleme mit Screensharing und Teams.
Da hat sich eindeutig, man sieht, das ist gar nicht mehr so aktuell bei vielen Sachen, was ich im Kopf habe.
Da hat sich die letzten zwei, drei Jahre wirklich ordentlich was getan.
Ja, OBS, das meine ich nicht.
Ich meine Teams-Screensharing.
So, ob OBS 1A funktioniert, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren. Sekunde. OBS. Oder dann war es irgendwie so, ja. So, schauen wir mal. Package. Ganz ehrlich, warum mache ich das eigentlich da drüber? Geh weg. Ich mache das einfach wie ihr gehabt. OBS.
OBS Studio? Ja, das Studio ist das aktuelle.
da ich bin
mama obs das immer next use current jawohl fps 60 next service custom gibt
es nicht so was wie ich will nicht streamen ich will nur lokal aufnehmen gibt es nicht
dass marco wie es nicht gut dann brechen wir das mal ab sagt es so
screen capture
mit western full workspace okay gut das von
schau mal gut das schon mal beruhigend dass man damit auch streamen könnte
aber keine gefällt mir wirklich gut ja was ich auch noch mal ausprobieren wollte guck mal hier
wenn wir jetzt sagen night light und machen das mal anhand von sunrise und sunset bald bald
was passiert denn wenn ich jetzt alles mal gucken wie der night mode aussieht
Ah, guck mal hier.
Eigentlich nice, oder?
Sunrise, Sunset.
Okay, noch was, was ich auch noch brauche, Chat.
Ich glaube ich
Ohne Scheiß, ich glaube es wird bei mir auf KDE rauslaufen
Was ich auch noch brauche
Jetbrains
Jetbrains Toolbox
Jetbrain Toolbox
Okay, da brauchen wir
Einen Auer, auch gut
Sehr gut.
Sandby, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
So, Jetbrains Toolbox haben wir installiert.
Kennst du River Classic?
Ne, hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Ich bin gerade so am hin und her switchen
zwischen Desktops und Rechnern.
Da übersehe ich einiges.
River Classic.
Ne, was ist das?
Kenn ich nicht.
Was ist River Classic?
Welcher Mini-PC?
Das ist ein...
Moment.
das ist ein Beelink
Seer 7.
Dieses Teil hier.
Mit einem 8-Core-Ryzen.
8G RAM.
Achso, was sagt der jetzt eigentlich?
Habe ich jetzt gar nicht geguckt.
Was sagt eigentlich hier?
3-M jetzt.
Ah, jetzt habe ich ordentlich.
Okay, jetzt habe ich ordentlich RAM.
Gut.
dynamic tailing ich bleibe ich habe sie überlegt ohne scheiß ich würde gerne mal mango wc und so
ausbringen aber ganz ehrlich ich glaube ich bleibe man muss mal immer gucken ich glaube
da ist einfach der support am besten also auch von neuen sachen und und fehler die behoben werden
alles ich glaube es ist gar nicht verkehrt auf auf kde zu setzen jetzt
hyperland oder niri ne ne ne wollte ich mir mal angucken
ich habe ein video letztens drüber gesehen sei ich ganz cool aus ich glaube
ich glaube ich lasse es bei kd mal ganz im ernst guck mal wenn ich hier teilen
window manager benutze hier war normal ich schalte mal um das ist ja ein
Tiling Window Manager.
In der Regel, zu 90%
benutze ich Fullscreen Windows und schalte
mit den Tasten dazwischen durch.
Also, das 90% habe ich hier
Fullscreen Windows Sachen.
Also, das Tiling an sich,
das benutze ich gar nicht so oft.
So, und
Tiling Scripts.
Hier brauche ich ja noch nicht einmal. Guck mal.
Ich kann einfach hier genau das gleiche machen.
Ja, Browser, Terminal, hier jetzt meine IDE.
Hier.
Poolbox.
Installieren wir jetzt, keine Ahnung, Goland oder so.
PyCharm.
Alles drauf.
Rider.
Sea Lion.
Rust Rover.
IDEs installieren.
Schauen wir mal kurz, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
H-Top.
Wie viele IO wir jetzt haben.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Gar nicht so viel.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken,
wie schnell eigentlich diese SSD ist.
das scaling beispielsweise ist unter x auch ganz abartig text scaling und
generell scaling und high dpi und geschichten das ist total abartig unter
unter x11
also es ist vieles nicht schön unter x das heißt aber nicht dass man wayland
für alles feiern muss, finde ich so, weil
da ist auch viel Schrott.
Da machst du ja auch nicht.
Sag nur.
Es gibt ja so Hardcore-Wayland-Fanatiker.
Immer noch am Start, nie wieder am Start.
Warum eigentlich CashUS?
Weil es aktuell der neue Hype ist.
Nee, nee, ich weiß.
Ich weiß, dass du nicht
der krasse Wayland-Verfechter bist.
gibt auch hardcore x11 fanatiker ich glaube es gibt nur einen es gibt nur einen
das ist der mit der der mit seinem x fork
Der mit seinem X-Fork, ja
Guck mal hier, wobbelt es nicht ganz toll
Hier das Fenster
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das ein Schwurbler ist
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das nur mit dem Fork verfolgt
Dass er sich auch gestritten hat
Mit den X-11 Leuten
Jaja, es gibt einen X-Fork
jetzt habe ich es lieber
er ist aber voll dabei hier
22 days ago
FreeBSD?
Nee, das ist Running On, nicht nur.
Oh hier, Releases. Guck mal, es gab erst ein neues Release vor ein paar Tagen.
Da wird was dran gebastelt.
Das habe ich auch gelesen
Letztens auf Twitter
Ich kriege aus irgendwelchen Gründen
In meinem Feed auf Twitter
Ganz viel Telekom Support
Posts empfohlen
Von Leuten, die sich beschweren
Und die immer mit ihrem
Hast du schon mal deinen Router überprüft?
Oder sowas
Und ja, wir haben das beste Netz
Ein Scheiß habt ihr Telekom
richtige scheiß habt ihr von wegen im besten netz
wartet mal wie das bei vodafone wird sind ja auch aus dem normalen piring ausgestiegen
ok jetbrains gedöns ist installiert jetzt sagen wir mal schauen wir mal wie gut die
sachen darauf laufen wir sollten vielleicht noch wenn wir
gerade dabei sind.net installieren.net sdk.net host.net runtime und dann
asp.net core muss auch noch installiert werden
ASP, Netcore,
Fronttime.
So.
Also es flutscht auf dem Mini-PC.
Kann man wirklich nicht anders sagen.
Also das läuft wirklich sehr flüssig und gut.
So, jetzt starten wir mal Rider.
Reader
Ähm, ist jetzt
Ist die Jetbrains Toolbox jetzt eigentlich hier unten?
Äh, Chat
Chat, ich bin verwirrt
Warum läuft hier
Mario Kart Musik? Geht das auch über
KDE Connect?
Das geht über KDE Connect?
KDE Connect kann ich die Musik
vom anderen Rechner aussteuern
Okay, das ist irgendwie cool
Ähm
Ja, Chat, sind jetzt die
Jetbrain Toolbox, ist die jetzt
noch da oder
läuft die da im Hintergrund oder
die hat übrigens kein Icon
Hier läuft die.
Kann man hier sagen?
Mini-Mais oder so?
Ne, die ist da wieder weg.
Okay.
Rider.
Dark.
Visual Studio Keymap.
ganzen mist brauche ich okay new solution xd new solution
also es läuft wirklich sehr flüssig hier drauf muss man echt mal sagen
jetzt schon ist es aber es ist ein kleiner unterschied zu vm kleiner
unterschied ist kein riesiger unterschied
okay ich soll mein wallet open ppo burn money
retrial has started ja ich weiß dass ich nicht eingeloggt bin
was ist mit rider? rider ist gecrashed oder? ne? rider ist einfach nur lahm
AF.
Boah!
Alter!
Was ist denn die TPU-Auslastung hier?
Rider! Hilfe!
Java! Lass mich in Ruhe!
Okay, jetzt
sind wir hier am Start.
So, was ich halt früher manchmal benutzt hab, ist
für teiling window manager ich habe halt hier die idee offen gehabt so und und
hatte dann hier noch irgendwie den extra extra fenster unten gibt
was leckten das so kalte was ist jetzt los
vom lecker so sieht ihr das wf
alter
jetzt moment jetzt
was ist das denn
Ist das hier auch so?
Ist es hier auch so?
Das ist jetzt bestimmt, weil es eine X-Anwendung ist, Leute.
Wollen wir wetten?
Das ist jetzt, weil es eine X-Anwendung ist.
Pass mal auf.
Config.
Enable Wayland True.
Jetzt stimmt mein Mauszeiger wieder nicht.
Ja, easy.
Guck.
Das ist, weil es eine X-Anwendung war.
Okay, ich habe also die Auswahl zwischen
einem laggy as fuck Terminal,
wenn man es resized,
oder dass man in einem Maus-Cursor stimmt.
Tja.
Was, was, was?
Was ist da jetzt besser, ne?
Vielleicht X11 plus Wobble.
Vielleicht ist das ein Problem, ja.
Das ist das beste Terminal, was es gibt.
West Term ist das beste.
Es gibt kein besseres Terminal.
An Kitty a la Kitty und was es sonst nicht alles gibt komplett einpacken.
Okay, suchen wir mal.
Western Wayland Cursor.
I use X11 and my mouse cursor theme does not seem to work.
Okay.
Was?
Okay, ich sehe,
das ist ein wenig komplizierter.
Wayland Cursor Theme Environment Variable.
Ist es jetzt gesetzt?
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Okay.
Daran wird es wohl liegen.
Und jetzt?
Export
Gleich
Keckel, ich weiß nicht was da rein muss
Äh
Jetzt ist der Cursor schon mal nicht kaputt
Nachdem ich es auf Keckel gesetzt habe
Aber
Er hat immer noch keinen richtigen Cursor
Immerhin
immerhin, wenn das auf Kekkel gesetzt ist.
Ja.
Windows-As-Rail-In-Pointer.
Set Cursor. Unable to set Cursor to X-Term.
Cursor not found.
Okay.
Was habe ich denn für Cursor-Themes
überhaupt?
Standardmäßig Fisch, ja.
X-Cursor-Theme.
Wayland.
How does Cursor-Theming work?
Okay.
das heißt moment das heißt ich kann hier gucken kursa wie das heißt captain kursus kursus
so das wird das setzen wir da jetzt kapitän kursus western und schon funst
Leute oder auch nicht
Ja wie jetzt ja was jetzt
Okay das liegt daran weil das andere drunter ist
Aber da kann es wieder nicht setzen
Unable to set cursor to x term
Cursor not found
Boah ey ganz ehrlich mit so einem Scheiß
Will ich mich eigentlich gar nicht beschäftigen
Wenn ich ehrlich bin
Da habe ich jetzt keinen F drauf.
Kann man nicht einfach sagen, weil er immer sagt, cannot set default.
Wenn ich hier sage default.
Dann ist dieser hässliche Cursor am Start.
Application Set. Ich glaube nicht, dass das das Problem ist.
Leute, ich kann nicht mehr klicken.
Mein Wayland-Menü geht...
Ah, okay, jetzt geht es wieder auf.
Application Style.
Und jetzt?
Das will ich nicht.
Ich will ja die Maus.
Hier, Knome GTK.
Ja, das hat aber nichts mit dem Maus-Cursor zu tun.
das liegt hier man hat ja gesehen sobald ich die variable richtig setzte geht's
also bald ich hier sage export irgendwie was also nicht richtig setzte x curser team der schi os
ja woher weiß ich denn den cursor team name
woher weiß ich das
ich bleibe bei zsh die will ich haben diese nice pibata cursor theme das
nehmen wir das nehmen wir das ist mega nice dass das ja das nehmen wir
wie barter cursor theme das ist das beste
immer lieber bin dort nicht drei stunden das was
erstmal auf sudo pacman minus update machen
aha system upgrade bern
jetzt wird das bestimmt auch oder auch nicht dann nehmen wir halt das zum
selbst kompilieren
Nee, Oh My Zish mag ich auch überhaupt nicht, Leute.
Oh My Zish.
Was ich hab, ist...
Ich hab ne eigene ZSH-Konf.
Und ein ordentliches Prompt-Theme. Fertig.
Mehr braucht die ganzen anderen Krempel nicht.
Guck mal, meine ZSH-RC, die hält sich wirklich...
was macht das da jetzt alles die hält sich wirklich sehr in grenzen der src
also da tut sich da tut sie nicht viel drin so irgendwelche zsh magic sachen nicht über
die jahre zusammen gesucht habe fragt mich gar nicht mehr was das zeug macht ich habe
werde ich gesagt, keine Ahnung. Ich kenne meine eigene
ZSH-Config nicht.
Ich habe das einfach so zusammengebaut über die Jahre
und es funktioniert so, wie ich das haben will.
Keine Ahnung, was das alles macht.
Absolut
kein Schimmer.
Wer braucht schon
Kommentare, wenn es einfach funktioniert?
Unset HisChars, keine Ahnung.
Das weiß ich nur, was das macht.
Das ist, dass ich mit 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9 die letzten Verzeichnisse
durchwechseln kann.
HisSize, ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es sogar
ein parameter dass die history unlimited ist irgendwelche thema fixes memory an
zwei es benutze ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr
alias für rdc des hi3 westerm wimmer c starship wetter anzeige ganz furchtbar
wichtig wichtigste überhaupt wetter eigentlich benutze ich das so gut wie
nie habe ich mir irgendwann mal gebaut und so ist es sogar broken geht gar nicht mehr
ist anscheinend kaputt wetter punkt es könnte auch unter wayland kaputt sein ehrlich gesagt
warum hat wim hier visual modus an das muss das muss sofort weg ich habe meine wimmer
erzähle ich gucke sofort weg wischel modus in wim das ist ein verbrechen aller
so
mein safe m funktion
image cat kann ich im terminal im terminal bilder anzeigen lassen
an ich zum beispiel sagen im mit cat pictures neben sie das ob hintergründe
documents keine ahnung kann ich nicht weil ich keine bilder hier ab
Yes!
Bibata Cursors können wir jetzt gleich auswählen und dann hoffentlich auch so setzen,
dass es funktioniert. Was genau passiert hier gerade? Wetterin ist tot, oh Settke!
ja ist der ist der schade zwar nicht geile seite
ich habe bin ich bei der telekom
ok also dann probieren wir das jetzt mal aus
Cursor.
Ah, Bibata Original
Amber.
Beste.
Apply.
Jawohl. Ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment, Moment. Das ist der falsche.
Bibata Modern Amber.
Jawohl.
Size
32.
Excellent.
also okay das probiert das jetzt noch mal zack zack beste beste kölner team
leute beste einfach beste excel exzellent exquisite export sowie heißt das ding jetzt
cursor theme.
B-Bata
minus
Modern minus
Amber. So,
let's turn.
Es geht, Leute.
Es...
Gott, diese Kleinigkeiten
immer. Diese Kleinigkeiten immer.
Guckt es euch an.
Seht ihr das hier? Guckt es euch an.
Okay,
da müssen wir noch X-Env setzen.
sei es
sei es geht auch irgendwie
wie setzt man die size davon sei es
x cursor size ok x kursus 32 export x vor allem die x kurs ersetzen muss das
ist eine wayland richtig funks auch geile leute so muss es sein exzellent
aber es geht immer noch nicht dass der das richtigen richtigen cursor anzeigt
West Ham does not show text select cursor
weil ein rutsch ich als
Ich will nicht den Cursor-Hiding-Bug.
Tja, das werden wir wahrscheinlich
nicht wieder richtig gefixt kriegen.
Das ist schon wieder ärgerlich.
Weil so ein Text-Select-Cursor ist schon ganz nice.
Ups.
was wir jetzt nochmal probieren können ist
config western
frontend
gleich software
gucken was passiert
nix
das hier ist richtig
guck das setzt er richtig
aber kein
das hat ziemlich das sagt
linux selection körper
nennt sich das selection, guck mal western github, das suchen wir jetzt mal danach
also
so
Okay, da finde ich jetzt nichts.
Cursor.
Und ich bin mir jetzt bei sowas halt extrem pingelig.
Chat, wie seht ihr das?
Würde es euch stören, dass es keinen Text-Selection-Cursor gibt?
Oder denkt ihr, das ist eigentlich egal?
Also ich bin da sehr pingelig.
Bei solchen Sachen, die ich mir jeden Tag mehrere Stunden angucke, will ich, dass das gescheit ist.
Ja, stört, ne?
Sehe ich auch so.
Pack mich ab.
Ah.
Ach das hier, okay, das ist natürlich nice.
Okay, das ist ein gutes Alias, die Cursor-Themes hier sich anzeigen zu lassen.
Hat einer erstmal Lua-Zeug für die Config programmiert?
okay western cuirass
link road sickness
Thickness.
Also ich vermute mal,
das ist einfach broken unter Wayland.
Dass der Maus-Cursor
gescheit funktioniert.
Also jetzt haben wir nur die Auswahl.
Leggy.
Oder
ordentlicher Maus-Cursor.
Ich meine, es ist auch relativ laggy hier in Twailand, aber...
Mal eine Frage aus deiner Erfahrung heraus.
Wie viel von dem, was du in deiner Ausbildung gelernt hast, wurde mir später im Berufsleben relevant,
dass die Prüfungsfragen der IHK völlig verhalten und schwachsinnig gestellt sind, glaube ich, allen klar.
Wie laggy ist es? Nur beim Resizen ist es laggy.
Also ist gar nicht so schlimm eigentlich.
Also, die IHK-Fragen sind tatsächlich dämlich.
Das hat mit der Realität nichts zu tun.
ich brauche immer noch relativ viel weil ich habe sehr viele sachen in der
ausbildung gelernt und die brauche ich heute immer noch oder zumindest so als
basis also ich habe viel von der ausbildung gelernt habe ist wichtig für
mich hängt aber halt auch immer ein bisschen ab was man für also wo man die
ausbildung gemacht hat wo man dann gelandet ist später aber du also ich
Ich brauche vieles davon.
So, ich shutdowne mal meine
Wayland-Kiste.
Weil ich jetzt was Abendessen
gehe. Leute, ich habe heute massig lang gestreamt.
Kann das sein?
So, Sekunde. Ich muss mal gerade hier wieder
kurz umstöpseln.
Gleich wieder am Start.
ist wieder vier stunden ordnung heute morgen war ich auch vier stunden oder so am start also heute
ich weiß es gibt streamer die machen jeden tag zwölf machen jeden tag zehn stunden plus wie
die das machen ich habe absolut nicht den hauch einer vorstellung ja was gibt's jetzt
großbrit
leben davon ja ich weiß aber ich kann es mir trotzdem nicht vorstellen ich merke das ja schon
jetzt wenn ich heute 24 stunden gestreamt habe da merke ich im hals ja
dass das ganz rau ist alles naja soll das nix
wer ist das die zwei sd ok ok
was ist das denn
Ich habe, ich checke
anhand der Beschreibung schon gar nicht, was es ist.
Das wäre einfach zu
zu high IQ.
Ach, vorhin habe ich schon ein paar Videos gesehen auf YouTube.
Das sind doch diese Videos mit
Colonel Def
fix oder irgendwie
Linux Kernel
Developer fixes a bug und sowas.
Den können wir hosten.
Ja, das ist okay. Das machen wir.
Oder wir können mal raiden.
Also Chat, wir raiden den jetzt.
Und ich gehe dann
mal
pepo pupu
und was essen.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
ihm es gefallen hat würde mich freuen euch im nächsten stream wiederzusehen
follow follow
und
Bis dann.
Oh, der hat Follow-Only-Chat?
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Aber gut, kann man nichts machen.
Ready to raid. Bis dann, Leute.
Macht's gut. See you.